sur Public
Sénat bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur
Public Sénat à suivre ce matin sur notre
antenne la suite de l'examen du projet
de loi Hôpital patients santé et
territoire les sénateurs devraient
terminer l'examen de ce texte
aujourd'hui ils entam en effet la
discussion du titre 3 sur la prévention
et la santé publique au cœur des débats
à la législation concernant la vente
d'alcool et de tabac les députés et les
sénateurs ont assoupli la version
initiale de ce texte il faut donc
s'attendre à ce que la ministre de la
Santé Roseline Bachelot essaie de
revenir à son projet de loi initial par
voie d'amendement voilà pour les enjeux
de la séance de ce matin bonne matinée à
tous monsieur le Président
ficher monsieur le Président selon une
étude prise par le docteur Brigitte
Sandrin Berton ministre médecin en santé
publique l'éducation thérapeutique a
pour but d'aider les patients à prendre
soin d'eux-mêmes à agir dans un sens
favorable à leur santé et à leur
bien-être une démarche qui s'inscrit
dans un processus entamé de longue dates
je pense par exemple à la charte d'Otawa
destiné à favoriser l'émergence du
concept de promotion de la santé qui
adopté en en
1986 a nourri l'ensemble de la réflexion
en santé publique et qui s'est notamment
concrétisé par un rapport remis par
l'OMS en mai
1996 intitulé thérapeutique patient
éducation ah oui ouais alors là je suis
pas bon
là alors cette notion vient donc
formaliser une activité qui était
jusqu'à présent considérée comme soi
dans leur pratique quotidienne les
soignants délivrent aux patients des
conseils qu'il répètent sans
véritablement de méthodes ainsi la force
de ce concept est de considérer que
l'éducation thérapeutique en ce qu'elle
permet de lutter contre des maladies
souvent longues faisant souvent l'objet
d'un classement dans la catégorie des
affections longue durée est un véritable
prolongement du soin nécessaire au
patient qui apprend à lutter contre elle
mais également à vivre avec elle mais
également utile aux professionnels de
santé puisque le suivi régulier de la
maladie par le patient lui-même permet
de contrôler la progression de la
maladie en ce sens et l'ensemble des
recherches menées sur le sujet la test
l'éducation thérapeutique du patient est
un prolongement du soin en tant que tel
au point que Jean-François d'vernois
professeur en sciences de l'éducation
n'hésite pas à considéré que les
programmes structurés d'éducation
thérapeutique sont à la fois un acte de
soin et la continuité des soins c'est
partant de cette réflexion et afin
d'empêcher les établissements
pharmaceutiques dont on sait que les
intérêts peuvent parfois être contraires
aux objectifs recherchés dans
l'éducation thérapeutique que nous
proposons que la dispensation de
l'éducation thérapeutique soit réservé
au seul éducateur et professionnel de
santé c'est tout le sens de notre
amendement cette inquiétude est par
ailleurs partagée puisque dans le
rapport pour une politique nationale
d'éducation thérapeutique du patient qui
vous a été remis récemment madame la
ministre les auteur annonce l'industrie
pharmaceutique se propose également de
conduire des actions sous la
dénomination de programme
d'accompagnement des patients ces
derniers s'inscrivent selon les auteurs
dans une logique de bon usage du
médicament mais soulève des
interrogations éthique stratégique et
opérationnel notre amendement nous
semble donc être très pertinent comme
tous les amendements qu'on dépose ah si
et être de nature à limiter la
participation directe des entreprises
pharmaceutiques qui sont comme chacun le
sait très intéressé à participer à de
tels programmes c'est à qu'ils y voi une
forme de fidélisation de leur clientèle
ce contre quoi nous ne pouvons que nous
élever voilà madame la ministre la
proposition d'ailleurs qui est formulée
par la Direction générale de la santé
vous comprendrez donc que nous ayons un
espoir un mince espoir mais quant à
l'adoption de notre amendement il est
satisfait monsieur le
présid quel est l'avis de la commission
monsieur le rapporteur oui monsieur le
président il n'est pas sûr qu'en
incluant les éducateurs les auteurs de
l'amendement atteignent leur objectif
d'encadrement de la dispensation
d'éducation thérapeutique car il n'y a
pas de définition des éducateurs il est
vrai qu'on ne peut pas non plus limiter
au seul professionnel de santé
l'éducation thérapeutique car ceci
écarterit les associations il est donc
préférable de s'en tenir à la rédaction
actuelle et c'est un avis
défavorable et du gouvernement madame la
ministre j'ai été très impressionné par
la thérapeuque
vous avez fait des études
VO euh
oui mais plus sérieusement je veux
d'abord dire qu'effectivement on l'a vu
l'éducation thérapeutique elle met
évidemment en pilotage au cœur du
dispositif les professionnels de santé
comm serait-il autrement mais elle
appelle comme je l'ai dit à une vision
de prise en charge globale de la mal du
malade et de la maladie qui fait
intervenir d'autres personnes on a parlé
de l'accompagnement associatif euh on a
évidemment pris évoquer cette prise en
charge médico-sociale si importante pour
les malades par exemple atteints de de
pathologies comme comme le sida donc des
travailleurs sociaux des psychologues et
vraiment réservé au seuls professionnels
de santé l'éducation thérapeutique
serait trop réducteur alors vous avez
évoqué les programmes dans lequel
intervient l'industrie pharmaceutique je
pense que vous faites une erreur il
s'agit pas des programmes
d'accompagnement mais des programmes
d'apprentissage ce qui n'a rien à voir
c'est il y a il y a à nouveau une
confusion qui est faite et qu'il faut
bien distinguer un programme d'accompagn
c'est pas un programme d'apprentissage
un programme d'apprentissage l'industrie
pharmaceutique qui intervient sur des
produits assez sophistiqués qui
demandent une mise en œuvre un
savoir-faire pour prendre son traitement
et effectivement qui mieux que
l'industriel le fabricant qui a mis au
point ce processus peut
être peut peut apprendre au
consommateurs malad à s'en servir
excusez-moi mais ça me paraît ça me
paraît une évidence alors bien sûr il y
a des dispositifs
d'encadrement et la loi fixe un cadre
destiné à la mise en œuvre de cette
éducation thérapeutique du
définit les compétences
spécifiques et évidemment comme je l'ai
dit mais les garde fous mais il faut que
chacun reste à sa place c'est la raison
pour laquelle je suis opposé à
l'amendement 519 bien plus personne ne
demande la parole mes chers collègue
monsieur
ficher je crois que nous voulions par
cet amendement préciser notre point de
vue mais en même temps je veux aussi
préciser que ce n'est pas un amendement
contre les assoc iation qui
participe véritablement à cet
accompagnement ce que nous voulons
dénoncer avant tout c'est le mode de
financement des associations
aujourd'hui nous savons que compte tenu
de la faiblesse des moyens dont elle
dispose
effectivement la source des ressources
notamment provenant des laboratoires
pharmaceutiques bon est une source non
négligeable pour le fonctionnement d'un
certain nombre d'associations et je
connais et je sais j'ai été sollicité
par notamment toutes les associations
qui luttent contre le sida qui lutent et
qui mène une action très sérieuse de
longue date que nous avons déjà reçu à
plusieurs reprises ce n'est pas contre
elle que nous voulons mais je crois que
si à la fois on pouvait clarifier leurs
ressources et notamment leur donner
d'autres moyens pour subsister que
celles venant des laboratoires
pharmaceutiques et bien là je crois
qu'il y aurait véritablement une
clarification et c'était dans ce sens-là
alors nous savons que notre amendement
ne sera pas voté mais je voulais
préciser cela pour qu'il n'y ait pas de
confusion et surtout pour dire que nous
continuerons bien entendu à soutenir les
associations qui œuvrent dans ce domaine
mais le problème du financement est posé
plus personne ne demande la parole mes
chers collègues dans ce cas-là je mets
au voie l'amendement 519 du président
ficher que ceux qui sont avis d'adopterz
bien le manifester en levant la
main merci avis
contraire merci aussi l'amendement n'est
pas adopté allez nous poursuivons par
une par un amendement 780 11
rectifié monsieur Donini merci monsieur
le président madame la ministre mes
chers collègues l'article 29 relatif à
l'éducation thérapeutique prévoit
désormais donc l'interdiction pour une
entreprise pharmaceutique de conduire
tout contact personnalisé toute démarche
directe d'information de formation ou
d'éducation à destination du public
relative donc à un médicament prescrit
toutefois il convient d'étendre ce
principe d'interdiction de tout contact
personnalisé et de toute démarche
directe des laboratoires pharmaceutiques
vers les patients aux actions
d'accompagnement qui ont pour but
d'apporter une assistance et un soutien
aux malades dans la prise en charge de
leur maladie et d'y inclure également
les démarches indirectes en effet les
laboratoirees pharmaceutique souhaitent
participer à des actions d'éducation
thérapeutique en organisant des
programmes d'accompagnement sur les
médicaments qu'il commercialise or comme
le préconisé Ligas dans son rapport de
décembre 2007 consacré à je cite
l'encadrement des programmes
d'accompagnement des patients associés à
un traitement médicamenteux financé par
les entreprises pharmaceutique pour
garantir une éducation thérapeutique de
qualité et cohérente il est fondamental
que le patient soit préservé de tout
contact de nature promotionnelle le
financement de ces programmes éducation
thérapeutique et accompagnement doit
être clair et transparent la création
d'un fond public national destiné à
alimenter des fonds publics régionaux
géré par l'agence régionale de santé
permet de répondre à ses exigences ce
fond pourra notamment être alimenté par
les entreprises pharmaceutique vous
l'aurez compris avec cet amendement plus
précis et protecteur pour les patients
que celui adopté en commission ou celui
que vous nous proposerit madame la
ministre nous entendons veiller à ce que
l'industrie pharmaceutique n'utilise pas
le prétexte de l'éducation thérapeutique
ou de lettes à l'observance pour en
réalité faire la promotion de ces
produits destinés à la vente chacun sait
que la logique de concurrence et la
course au profit qui guide l'industrie
pharmaceutique ne serait placer
prioritairement l'intérêt des patients
au cœur de leur démarche c'est
conformément à cette volonté que je vous
invite madame la ministre à soutenir cet
amendement que je vous demande mes chers
collègues de le voter cet amendement
répond aussi à l'exigence
d'impartialité un principe essentiel de
la sécurité sanitaire puisqu'il consiste
à distinguer les considérations
économiques des considérations
très bien bravo merci Monsieur
dodini le gouvernement 1264 madame la
ministre un
amendement je vais monsieur le Président
si vous me autorisez répondre à Monsieur
dadini je ne reprendrai pas la
parole parce que ça éclaire
effectivement mon amendement
1264 je souhaite introduire par
l'amendement euh
euh une disposition qui proscrit tout
contact direct de l'industrie avec le
patient ça c'est tout à fait c'est tout
à fait important et c'est éthiquement
absolument indispensable mais monsieur
dodini vous allez plus loin puisque euh
votre amendement interdit tout contact
même
indirect alors d'abord c'est une notion
extrêmement floue qu'est-ce que c'est
qu'un contact indirect et cela peut
prêter à confusion parce que la
participation des laboratoires et et à
des actions et des programmes ne peut
être exclu soit dans le cadre d'un
cofinancement ou par la mise à
disposition d'outils d'information on en
parlait à l'instant avec l'amendement
précédent c'est le laboratoire qui en
général connaît comment on se se sert
d'un produit parfois d'une manière assez
complexe mais évidemment cela doit être
fait dans le cadre d'un cahier des
chararts national en toute transparence
en particulier pour les malades leur
entourage ou leurs représentants sous le
suivi et le contrôle des agences
régional de santé avec également la
possibilité de contrôle de la conformité
des programmes par les organismes
experts l'INPES
laahas lafsaps et c'est la raison pour
laquelle je je je clarifie les choses
par mon amendement
1264 qui vise donc à préciser comme je
vous l'ai dit l'absence de lien direct
entre les entreprises des médicaments ou
des dispositifs médicaux parce que il y
a aussi cela et les patients ou leur
entourage et dans le cadre des principes
que j'ai évoqué d'ailleurs en préambule
l'interdiction de tout contact direct
constitue un préalable éthique et
déontologique intangible pour élaborer
et mettre en œuvre les programmes ou
actions d'éducation thérapeutique
d'accompagnement ou d'apprentissage donc
je je pense avoir répondu à votre souci
éthique en mettant également tout au
long du texte les dispositifs qui
permettront dans des de manière très
encadrée et
transparente aux entreprises de pouvoir
financer ou mettre à disposition
cofinancer ou mettre à disposition des
outils
d'information et l'amendement
517 de monsieur le Président ficher ou
de Monsieur
hatin allez Monsieur François
hatin
oui si l'on veut effectivement éviter
que les laboratoires pharmaceutique
entre en contact avec les patients
éligibles au programme d'action
thérapeutique il faut préciser que ces
contacts peuvent être non seulement
direct mais aussi
indirect cette précision est
indispensable le rapport de Ligas
relative à l'observance le précise très
clairement dans un paragraphe grave du
rapport intitulé consacrer le principe
de l'interdiction de tout contact direct
ou indirect entre laboratoire
pharmaceutique et publ et je pense que
ce concept de contact indirect doit être
suffisamment clair pour ce qu'il est
pour qu'il ait fait l'objet du titre
d'un chapitre du rapport de Ligas je dis
ça pour répondre à le ministre qui à
l'instant disait que cette notion de
contact indirect ne correspondait pas
quelque chose de de de de de palpable or
il semble bien que ce soit le contraire
d'autant plus que euh je vais l'indiquer
à l'instant puisque notre amendement en
ajoutant le mot ou indirect après les
mots contact direct ne fait que
reprendre ce qui apparaît
systématiquement dans le code de la
sécurité sociale et le code de la santé
publique à chaque fois que la
législation veut proscrire des lien le
terme direct n'est alors jamais seul il
va toujours de pè avec le terme indirect
l'oublier c'est pervertir la disposition
en permettant son contournement
donc il est à mon sens absolument
indispensable d'ajouter ind direct le
mot indirect sinon je crois que on
natteindra pas l'objectif qui est
recherché à savoir créer une étanchéité
entre le laboratoire et ceux qui font
l'éducation
thérapeutique alors quel est l'avis de
la commission sur ces amendements
monsieur le rapporteur monsieur le
Président sur le 791 rectifié du groupe
socialiste l'interdiction de tout
contact indirect abouti à la fin de la
participation des programmes et actions
par les entreprises ce qui met en péril
les associations de patients en l'état
actuel il vaut mieux rester réaliste
c'est donc un avis défavorable pour
l'amendement 1264 du gouvernement c'est
un amendement rédactionnel utile c'est
donc un avis favorable et pour
l'amendement 517 du groupe C SPG cet
amendement est encore plus large que
l'amendement du groupe socialiste dans
l'interdiction est dictée c'est donc un
avis
défavorable alors madame le ministre
vous n'avez pas donné votre appréciation
sur le 517 il est logiquement
défavorable
monsieur alors Monsieur suer explication
de
vote merci monsieur le Président de me
donner la parole madame la ministre mes
chers collègues j'ai promis à des
médecins qui m'ont contacté de défendre
amendement 791 de Jean-Pierre Michel qui
a été défendu par notre collègue Yv
dodign en effet d'ailleurs Monsieur
Michel qui est comme vous savez un fin
juriste est
très qu'est-ce qu'il y a madame la
ministre
d'accord bon je leur ai dit Madame la la
ministre que je défendrai cet amendement
parce que cet amendement est conforme à
mon intime conviction cela vous
convient-il madame la ministre voilà
nous sommes réconciliés ça va mieux
qu'hier soir sur les plateaux télévisés
bon alors madame la ministre nous sommes
persuadé que dans ce domaine il faut une
stricte séparation des pouvoirs des
missions et des fonction et il est
extrêmement important que l'on distingue
les opération de promotion qui sont
faites par les laboratoires et les
industries pharmaceutiques de
l'éducation thérapeutique et c'est le
sens de notre amendement il nous paraît
absolument
essentiel que
l'interdiction porte aussi sur les
actions d'accompagnement
ou sur ce qui est indirect parce qu'à
partir du moment où l'on exclut ce qui
est l'accompagnement et ce qui est
indirect et bien on permet de très
nombreuses incursions de l'action
promotionnel dans l'éducation
thérapeutique et ainsi il y a le risque
de dévoyer l'éducation thérapeutique à
des fins promotionnelles c'est tout à
fait clair et madame la ministre je
pense que vous avez été vous-même
extrêmement sensible au rapport qui vous
a été is par l'excellente
IGAS en décembre 2007 et vous savez très
bien que ce que nous proposons par notre
amendement comme ce que a proposé
monsieur hatin par son amendement est
strictement conforme aux recommandations
du rapport de 2007 de liigas et nous
pensons que si Ligas est vigilante quant
à
l'accompagnement mais je suis d'accord
monsieur le Président il s'agit de
recommandation mais nous avons bien le
droit qui fait la ce n'est pas Ligas qui
fait la loi mais nous avons le droit au
Parlement de citer les recommandations
qui figurent dans un rapport public de
liigas remis à madame la ministre de la
Santé qui demande encore la parole plus
personne dans ce cas-là mes chers
collègues ah Monsieur
Vassel explication de vote
euh moi je je suis surpris qu'on attache
autant d'importance à la rédaction de ce
texte autant que je sache celui qui
prescrit c'est bien c'est bien le
médecin le risque le plus important
c'est celui de la relation de
l'entreprise avec le médecin
l'information du patient bien entendu il
faut qu'elle soit encadré mais ce n'est
pas l'entreprise qui va aller prescrire
au patients la consommation de tel ou
tel médicament donc il faut relativiser
un peu dans tout cela et dernière
dernière considération monsieur le
président moi je suis assez sceptique
quant à l'application que devront faire
les magistrats sur la notion de
l'entourage du patient l'entourage où ça
on peut imaginer où ça commence avec
l'entourage familial mais on peut se
demander où ça se termine est-ce que la
jurisprudence dans ce domaine est
suffisamment claire pour qu'on puisse
introduire dans la loi une notion
d'entourage du patient que l'entourage
du patient ça peut éventuellement aller
très loin on peut considérer que
quelqu'un qui habite à à Marseille pour
une personne qui habite à Lille faire
partie de son entourage parce que il y a
un lien familial qui le rapproche et qui
sont en contact téléphoniquement
régulièrement donc moi cette
notionentourage je suis surpris que ce
ce terme est une valeur juridique alors
je ne suis pas un juriste membre de la
commission des lois mais c'est une
simple interrogation que je voulais
exprimer devant vous
bien si plus personne ne demande la
parole je vais mettre au voix
l'amendement
791 rectifié de Monsieur daudini que
ceux qui sont d'IS d'adopté veuillez
bien manifester en levant la
main avis
contraire l'amendement n'est pas adopté
alors l'amendement du Gouvernement
1264 que ceux qui sont d VI adopté
veuille bien le manifester en levant la
main
avis
contraire l'amendement est adopté et le
tombe allez nous
poursuivons toujours à l'article 22 par
amendement 520 sur le président ficher
monsieur et
benavant
oui merci monsieur le Président les
programmes d'action thérapeutique ou
d'observance ne peuvent permettre
une
légalisation en douce d'une forme de
publicité directe auprès du grand public
pour des médicaments de
prescription la publicité directe pour
les médicaments de prescription comme en
témoigne l'expérience menéein les les
aux États-Unis en 2006 ou encore en
nouvelle a des retombées financières
très importantes car ell s'accompagnent
d'une très forte augmentation de la
prescription en découle des risques pour
la santé publique notamment à travers
les cas de ythrogénie médicamenteuse en
second lieu les est difficile d'imaginer
sur un marché compétitif qu'une firme
pharmaceutique puisse animer ou
participer à l'animation de l'éducation
thérapeutique sans pousser le patient à
la consommation ou à des mé ou du ou des
médicaments ou dispositifs qu'il
commercialise enfin comme le rappelle
Ligas dans son rapport sur l'observance
la personne malade face à sa maladie est
en situation de dépendance elle n'est
pas à même de juger sereinement et ne
peut se comporter en acheteur avisé
comme pour n'importe quel autre produit
du marché la dernière raison pour
s'opposer à ce que les programmes
d'observance puissent prendre une forme
publicitaire ou promotionnelle et donc
éthique c'est la raison de notre
amendementis de la commission quel est
l'avis de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur monsieur le Président la la
précision peut-être intéressante même si
on peut penser que le cahier des charges
prévoira et que les dispositions du Code
de la Santé sur l'interdiction de la
publicité le satisfont en partie c'est
donc un avis de sagesse en attendant
l'avis du Gouvernement et bien nous
allons écouter l'avis du
gouvernement c'est un avis défavorable
effectivement c'est une notion
antinomique avec le concept et la
définition même de l'éducation
thérapeutique du patient euh mais c'est
une préoccupation que évidemment je je
je partage et que nous mettrons bien
évidemment nous mettrons ces précaution
dans le cahier des charges nationales
comme l'a excellemment rapporté le
rapporteur cahier des charges nationales
auquel l'ensemble des programme devra se
conformer et là aussi je veux répondre à
à à la discussion sur
l'amendement précédent euh les les les
industries pharmaceutiques ne
participeront pas au programme
d'accompagnement du patient ils
participeront au programme
d'apprentissage d'observance du
traitement et je rejoins d'ailleurs
excellemment ce qu'a dit Monsieur Alain
Bassel le le traitement il est prescrit
par un médecin et on appelle
l'industriel à donneré
évidemment la la la méthode
pour que ce malade et parfois son
entourage parce que l'entourage est
souvent appelé à l'observance du
traitement je je pense par exemple sur
les poches pour snomi par exemple ù le
le l'entourage du malade l'entourage de
l'opéré est très souvent appelé à poser
ses poches mais ça peut qui mieux que
l'industriel souvent qui est à l'origine
de ces dispositifs médicaux peut
apprendre au malade et à son entourage à
s'en servir et il va pas utiliser plus
de
poches
effectivement parce que le le
l'industriel sera appelé à lui indiquer
comment on s'en sert enfin évidemment
tout cela c'est sont les programmes
d'apprentissage et et véritablement je
veux donc ainsi répondre à la au souciis
exprimés par les uns et les autres et
c'est la raison pour lequelle j' metis
un avis défavorable parce que je veux là
encore avoir une approche extrêmement
pragmatique demande encore la parole
chers collègues allez monsieur
hatin j'avoue madame la ministre que je
vous comprends pas puisque si j'ai bien
compris hein nous sommes d'accord sur
l'objectif que nous poursuivons à
travers cet amendement et vous allez
même l'intégrer je pense dans vos
décrets donc pour quelle raison pour
quelle raison ne pas vouloir l'inscrire
dans la
loi oui bah oui mais je trouve que bien
euh je mets au voix l'amendement 520 de
Monsieur hatin que ce qui veulent
l'adopter le manifeste en levant la main
merci avis contraire allez l'amendement
n'est pas adopté un amendement
792 de Monsieur Le Men merci monsieur le
Président Madame la Ministre cet
amendement vise à préciser les critères
qui définiront l'évaluation de
l'éducation qui définiront l'évaluation
de l'éducation thérapeutique il s'agit
d'une question sont de bon sens ces
critères doivent être établis au niveau
national tout en tenant compte des
situations locales cela va de soi en
effet chacun sait qu'il existe de fortes
différences régionales qu'il s'agisse
des pathologies ou des thérapies dès
lors il convient de préciser davantage
la relation qui existe entre des
critères d'ordre national et le respect
des spécificités locales la géographie
des territoires est ainsi appelée à
prendre une part de plus en plus grande
dans le débat sur la santé nous savons
bien ici que certains départements sont
plus touchés par exemple par l'obésité
infantile que d'autres c'est le cas par
par exemple du de la Dordogne par
rapport au nordpcalais le nordpcalais
étant plus touché je prends un autre
exemple celui de la Guyane lors de la
mission effectuée au cours d'une
délégation sénatoriale chargée d'étudier
la situation sanitaire et sociale en
Guyane en juillet 1999 on a pu constater
à quel point les problèmes de santé
publique étaient marqués par la
géographie ainsi l'existence et la
propagation endémique de maladies
infectieuse s'expliquant s'explique par
l'organisation urbaine l'incidence du
paludisme la lèpre et le virus de la
dangue qui s encore actuellement sont
des singularités qui ne peuvent être
comprises qu'en prenant en compte les
jeunes des individus et les réalités
locales je doute que l'évaluation au
niveau national confié au conseil de
santé publique seul et en particulier à
sa commission spécialisée dans les mal
les maladies chroniqu les incapacités
soit ici d'un grand secours sans le
concours notamment des observatoires
régionaux de santé ce qui justifie notre
amendement l'habit de la commission
monsieur le rapporteur monsieur le
Président l'amendement tel qu'il est
rédigé vise le cahier des charges
national et pas l'évaluation la
précision ne paraît pas nécessaire pour
le cahier des charges et l'évaluation
par la HAS telle qu'elle est prévu par
le texte suffit c'est donc un avis
défavorable et du gouvernement madame la
ministre et bien je vais monsieur le
Président si vous m'autorisez répondre à
la fois cet amendement et au suivant qui
parle des spécificités de l'outremire et
à travers la l'intervention de Monsieur
Leen je crois qu'il y a une très grande
confusion
que j'ai essayé de lever d'ailleurs dans
l'amendement liminaire en faisant bien
la différence entre l'éducation à la
santé et l'éducation
thérapeutique monsieur le vous n'avez
parlé finalement que de politique de
prévention quand vous parlez par exemple
de l'obésité ou des spécificités
d'outrem à travers un certain des
spécificités territoriales donc don de
l'outrem à travers des des différences
territoriales bien sûr qu'il faut
adapter les politiques de prévention au
terrain bien entendu il faudra peut-être
aussi l'adapter au aux données
géographiques dans certaines dans
certaines pathologies je le comprends
bien mais surtout il faut l'adapter aux
malades donc véritablement il y a un
cahier des charges national et
l'adaptation elle se fait à travers des
programmes qui peuvent relever de
l'agence régionale de santé mais qui
relève surtout d'un accompagnement
personnalisé donc ne confondons pas la
prévalence de de certaines dans certains
facteurs de morbidité et de mortalité
dans les politiques de prévention qui
seront régionalisé et les politiques
d'éducation thérapeutique qui seront
individualisées et là vraiment je la
confusion comme le progrès fait
rage qui demande encore la parole mes
chers collègues alors dans ce cas-là je
m au voix l'amendement
792 présenté par Monsieur Leem que ceux
qui sont Davis d'adopté veuille bien le
manifester en levant la main merci avis
contraire merci aussi l'amendement n'est
pas adopté alors sur l'amendement
rectifié monsieur
Desessard monsieur le Président c'est un
grand plaisir pour moi de défendre
l'amendement présenté par Monsieur
Antoinette patient Gillot Larcher lise
tu Ava
donc je voulais excuser monsieur
Antoinette qui est retourné en Guyane à
cause des élections européennes vous
aura pas échappé qu'il y a des élections
européennes dimanche par contre il
m'aura échappé à moins qu'on a eu une
semaine parlementaire pour participer
aux divers débats meeting et tout ça
hein donc nous sommes là en séance le
vendredi dans 2 jours alors comme si
l'Europe n'était pas importante et que
il y avait pas un certain nombre de
directives européennes qu'on était
obligé de inscrire donc je pense queon
aurait pu avoir une semaine pour
participer pleinement à la campagne des
européennes cela étant dit je vais
essayer de
défendre avec vigueur passion
motivation l'amendement présenté par
Monsieur Antoinette il propose d'insérer
une phrase ainsi rédigée ce cahier des
charge national proposera le le cas
échéant les adaptations utiles au
programme d'éducation thérapeutique
devant tenir compte de particularités
locales notamment dans les régions
départements et collectivités
d'outrem cet amendement vise à s'assurer
que les cahiers des charges nationaux
seront applicables dans les programmes
d'éducation thérapeutique et les
programmes d'accompagnement mis en œuvre
localement lorsque le contexte sanitaire
les car les caractéristiques
socioculturelles et linguistiques des
populations les contraintes
territoriales et celles auxquelles sont
soumis les acteurs en charge de Cees
programmes imposeront des adaptations ou
des aménagements
particuliers il paraît par exemple
évident que les programmes
d'accompagnement ou d'éducation
thérapeutique du patient en Guyane par
exemple seront marqués par les
caractéristiques socio-économiques et
culturelles des populations les
relations particulières à la santé et à
la médecine occidental les contraintes
d'éloignement et de coût celles de la
démographie médicale et mobiliseront en
cons
ticul
vraisemblablement différents que dans
l'exagone voilà donc madame la ministre
a bien senti l'esprit de ces différents
amendements que nous avons présenté
c'est qu'il y a une
spécificité outreem en particulier en
guyan et C amendement et les suivants
veulent que nous en tenions compte voilà
monsieur le Président l'esprit de cet
amendement présenté par Monsieur
Antoinet qui je le répète ne peut être
là parce qu'il y a un vote dimanche
prochain très bien alors monsieur le
rapporteur il aura pas échapper à
Monsieur de cessar que cette loi prévoit
la création d'agence régionale de santé
et que c'est donc à l'intérieur des
agences que c'est donc aux agences
régionales de santé qu'il appartiendra
de mesurer l'adaptation des programmes
au besoins locaux donc c'est un avis
défavorable à l'amendement et
gouvernement vous l'avez déjà donné
madame la ministre bon c'est négatif
dans ce cas-là si plus personne ne
demande la parole je mets au voix
l'amendement de Monsieur Desessard que
ceux qui sont d d'adopté veillent bien
le manifester en levant la main et merci
avis
contraire merci aussi l'amendement n'est
pas adopté allez esprit de Dieu qui
souffle sur moi à une voix près mais
qu'est-ce que vous voulez faire oh ça
était souvent le cas dans la République
hein allez euh
688 rectifié toujours de Monsieur
Desessard don de Madame
Blandin merci cet amendement est motivé
par les mêmes considérations que le
précédent mais j'espère qu'il aura
meilleur sort afin de mieux vous
convaincre peut-être faut-il vous
rappeler la réalité locale par exemple
en Guyane vie au plus près du fleuve des
amersindiens consommation essentielle de
protéines de poisson contamination de
l'eau et des poissons par le mercure de
l'orpillage sauvage cela demande des
messages spécifiques et puisque monsieur
le rapporteur vous évoquez la future
ARS plaidons ensemble pour qu'un
antiller guyané s'en occupe afin qu'il
soit bien adapté lui aussi à passer des
messages spécifiques locaux pour ce qui
est de l'accompagnement thérapeutique
ind
indidualisé dont vous précisez madame la
ministre qu'il est le cœur de cible de
cet article et j'entends bien votre
appel à la
précision je veux aussi plaider la
nécessité d'adéquation et de prise en
charge spécifique par deux exemples
simples la file d'attente pour le sida à
l'hôpital de Saint-Laurent du Maroni est
considérable mais les échecs du TR
tritement viennent d'un tabou global
culturel qui pèse là-bas vis-à-vis des
gens contaminés cela exige un
accompagnement thérapeutique discret
particulièrement spécifique 2ème chose
le traitement du
paludisme beaucoup de gens hélas
participent au chantier d'orpaillage
sauvage ils sont médicalement suivis
mais on leur offre des médicaments
illicite venu du Brésil beaucoup plus
d'osés qui font qu'ils sont sur pied dès
le lendemain pour retourner au chantier
le problème c'est qu'il continue à se
faire piquer par le fameux moustique et
l'InVS dit c'est un véritable
laboratoire de fabrique de souches
résistant pour le paludisme et ben vous
voyez il y a des messages spécifiques à
faire passer pour ceux qui sont sont en
train de suivre un traitement voilà deux
exemples j'espère que nous aurons une
voix de plus qui permettra de faire
basculer l' vie vers le
favorable alors monsieur le rapporteur
peut-on connaître l'avis de la
commission et encore une fois monsieur
le Président c'est la RS qui devra
assurer le contrôle et c'est la RS qui
devra adapter au besoins locaux donc
avis défavorable du gouvernement madame
la
ministre là aussi y a une très grande
confusion vous expliqué madame Blandin
qu'il avait un cahier des charges
national qui définissait des bonnes
pratiques des protocoles vous allez pas
mettre la déclinaison régionale dans le
cahier des chares nationales c'est
complètement incohérent et bien sûr
ensuite au niveau régional on fait cette
on fait cette déclinaison et ensuite
parce que c'est ça l'éducation
thérapeutique on
adapte tout l'ensemble de ces protocoles
déclinés à à au mal à sa spécificité la
spécificité de son cas la spécificité de
son entourage de son milieu
socio-économique de ses habitudes
culturelles vous avez fort bien souligné
que les populations amérindiennes
demandaient une éducation thérapeutique
qui ne serait sans doute relevé en
Guyane du technicien de haut niveau de
la base de courou donc effectivement on
va sans doute mettre un protocole par
exemple pour un malade atteint du VIH ça
relève de protocole d'accompagnement
nationaux d'une déclinaison régionale
étant donné la prévalence de l'épidémie
du VIH en Guyane et j'ai reçu je le
signalais à Monsieur Desessard
d'ailleurs hier le préfet de Guyane et
j'ai évidemment bien insisté auprès de
lui sur un certain nombre auprès de
Monsieur le Préfet Ferret pour qu'il y
ait un suivi très
particulier lutte contre l'immigration
clandestine la prostitution sur les
zones d'orpaillage est évidemment un
facteur de transmission du VIH la notion
des perdu de vue qui est un élément sur
lequel je veux que nous ayons des
objectifs chiffrés atteints pour que
diminuer cette ces perdu de vue en
Guyane pour l'observance du traitement
bien sûr nous faisons tout cela mais
véritablement excusez-moi de vous le
dire mais votre amendement je vous
demande de de le retirer il est
absolument pas
logique
bon monsieur Desessard l'exlication de
vote je reprends le
texte les programmes d'éducation
thérapeutique du patient sont conformes
à un cahier des charges nationales dont
les modalités d' d'élaboration et le
contenu sont définis par arrêté du
ministre chargé de la santé tout va bien
ces programmes sont mis en œuvre au
niveau local et on veut rajouter les
mots et
adapter
franchement alors on pourrait
dire mais on dit que c'est au niveau
local oui mais au niveau local il y a eu
des périodes le gouvernement il disait
peu importe la situation c'est la règle
elle doit s'appliquer partout de la même
façon c'est aussi au niveau local que
s'applique une politique qui est la même
partout j'ai bien
compris que la ministre le rapport
le président de la commission sont
favorables au fait que ça soit
adapté o ça où ça
oui
ça
exactement mais écoutez le mot adapté je
ne sais pas combien de lettres le a le D
le a le P le T les e e et le S c'est
peut-être H8 lettres on demande et oui
mais on est toujours satisfait de on est
toujours satisfait mais lorsqu'on
demande à ce qu'on mettre le mot adapté
pour tenir compte des spécificités alors
que tout le monde est d'accord personne
veut le mettre dans le texte enfin c'est
quand même pas possible c'est quandême
on vous avez mis personnalisé pour dire
que ça soit des personnalisé
pour le
patient là oui non parce que là on on
dit qu'il faut tenir compte de la
spécificité du territoire concerné c'est
quand même tout à fait différent donc
c'est alors qu'on est tous d'accord ça
devrait être très simple de pouvoir
l'adopter que le président àou si vous
le dites au micro c'est
mieux pourrait mettre recalibré adapté
et personnalisé je sais pas quels sont
les vous oublie peut-être des adjectifs
qui pourrai peut-être mieux le préciser
alors devant cette précision c'est plus
allez mes chers collègues si plus
personne ne demande la parole je mets au
voix
l'amendement de Monsieur Desessard que
ceux qui sont d'Avid adopté veillez bien
manifester en levir la main on va bien
compter avis
contraire allez l'amendement n'est pas
adopté allez l'amendement
1265 du gouvernement madame la
ministre alors je je veux vous parler
par cet
amendement des modalités d'évaluation et
de suivi des programmes d'éducation
thérapeutique du patient et là
finalement on continue la discussion que
nous avons eu sur le fait qu'il faut
aller beaucoup plus loin que
l'adaptation il faut personnaliser si je
n'ai pas voulu du terme d'adaptation
c'est parce que il est beaucoup plus
faible que le terme de de de
personnalisation euh et euh je veux par
cet amendement poursuivre un double
objet mettre les agences régionales de
santé nous en avons parlé au cœur du
dispositif en leur donnant une mission
d'évaluation en matière d'éducation
thérapeutique du patient sur la base du
cahier des charges nationales
et puis je veux aussi les soutenir ces
ARS dans leur mission d'autorisation de
renouvellement
d'autorisation en créant une commission
nationale regroupant les principaux
acteurs et experts nationaux en matière
d'éducation thérapeutique du patients
l'INPES l'éducation l'Institut national
de prévention et d'éducation pour la
santé qui a la mission d'établir les
critères de qualité des supports des
programmes en éducation thérapeutique
c'est l'article L 14 17 5 du code de la
santé publique la hasas qui entre autres
missions élabore les recommandations de
bonnes pratique évalue la qualité des
pratiques médicales et de soins article
L161 37 du code de la sécurité sociale
lafsaps qui fournit l'expertise pour le
bon usage du médicament article l531 2
du code de la santé publique et les
représentants nationaux des associations
d'usager en charge de la défense des
droits des malades et d'action de
formation et
d'information
cette commission de recours association
d'usagers monsieur nous avons le
sénateur nous avons déjà eu des une une
discussion sur ce sujet il
est alors écoutez on
est ne vous réfugiez pas derrière les
discussions sémantiques cette commission
de recours aura ainsi toutes les
compétences requises permettant
d'émettre des avis à la demande des ARS
sur la qualité des programmes
d'éducation thérapeutique et sur leur
conformité au cahier des charges ce que
nous voulons c'est renforcer
l'évaluation des programmes d'éducation
thérapeutique du patient au plan
régional afin de sensibiliser les
acteurs de terrain et les ARS à cette
démarche qualité dès le lancement du
dispositif il sera plus adapté aux
réalités local de permettre aux ARS de
réaliser l'évaluation des programmes
d'éducation thérapeutique sur la base
d'un cahier des charges national plutôt
que de surcharger le niveau national en
particulier la Haute Autorité de Santé
en faisant remonter pour évaluation les
centaines voire même les milliers de
programmes en je sais pas si si vous
voyez le le le le système en antennoir
renversé que nous construirions si nous
faisions remonter l'évaluation complète
de ces programmes à la Haute Autorité de
Santé et et d'ailleurs nous perdrions
cette faculté d'adaptation cette
évaluation d'adaptation souhaité par
certains d'autre part en amont de
l'autorisation du renouvellement
d'autorisation accordé par l' RS
l'autorité administrative pourra saisir
cette commission placé auprès de l'INPES
pour s'assurer de la qualité des
programmes elle réunira l'expertise de
lafsaps acquise grâce à la Commission de
contrôle de la publicité celle de la HAS
dans les domaines de l'évaluation des
actes professionnels et de
l'amélioration de la qualité des soins
et donc celle de l'INPES pour ce qui est
des méthodes de communication et de
prévention centré sur une approche
patient la HAS fera ainsi bénéficier le
dispositif de son expertise comme elle
pourra le faire lors de l'évaluation
globale du dispositif qui devra porter
sur son implantation son impact son
intérêt médico-économique et le recours
à cette instance permettra donc d'éviter
des contentieux préjudiciable au
développement de ces programmes tout en
assurant leur qualité c'est pour
pourquoi je vous demande d'accepter cet
amendement sur les modalités
d'évaluation et de suivi des programmes
d'éducation thérapeutique du patient qui
veut déconcentrer le système et Monsieur
Desessard
l'adapter alors l'avis de la commission
monsieur le rapporteur oui monsieur le
Président la question fondamentale sur
l'éducation thérapeutique est de savoir
si elle est bénéfique pour la santé des
patients on ne peut donc considérer
qu'il s'agit d'une simple question d'
formation dès lors comme le prévoit le
texte de la commission c'est à la HAS
d'évaluer les programmes une évaluation
est d'ailleurs préférable à un simple
contrôle de conformité au cahier des
charges comme le propose l'amendement du
Gouvernement chaque instance doit être
dans son rôle lafsaps exercera un
contrôle sur les programmes
d'apprentissage comme le prévoit le
texte de la commission peut-être l'impè
pourrait-elle évaluer les actions
d'accompagnement mais en aucun cas
chapauter une commission de contrôle il
n'y a aucune raison de limiter les
compétences de la Haute Autorité de
santé en matière d'éducation
thérapeutique et celle-ci s'associera
naturellement à l'impess à la saaps en
cas de besoin dès lors la commission a
émis un avis défavorable à à
l'amendement du
gouvernementvorable explication de
vote bon monsieur monsieur
hatin effectivement je je je trouve que
le texte proposé par la Commission est
bien préférable à celui proposé dans cet
amendement euh j'estime que c'est à la
Haute Autorité de Santé de d'intervenir
dans ce domaine et je suis quant à moi
très réservé hein
sur l'intervention des associations dans
ce domaine dont le rapporteur a dit avec
juste raison que ces associations
dépendaient des entreprises
pharmaceutiques hein c'est le terme
exacte qu'il a utilisé tout tout à
l'heure et qui correspond effectivement
à la réalité c'est vrai que nous en
saurons plus lorsque sera appliqué cette
disposition qui prévoit que chaque année
les laboratoires doivent publier la
liste des association qu'il finance mais
c'est vrai que on peut s'interroger sur
le degré
d'indépendance des associations qui sont
financé par le laboratoire dans un
domaine quand même qui concerne la
commercialisation d'un certain
de médicaments par ces mêmes
laboratoires qui les subventionn alors
effectivement on a encore peu
d'informations sur le montant de ces de
ces subventions mais mais non mais c'est
pas c'est pas le sujet c'est ça que vous
voulez dire mais c'est quand même très
important je pense qu'il faut établir me
semble-t-il un contrôle beaucoup plus
strict sur les modes de financement des
associations si elles n'ont pas les
moyens de
de mener leur action par manque de
financement il serait bon c'est ce qu'a
dit d'ailleurs mon collègue tout à
l'heure gu ficher que l'État que le
gouvernement que la sécurité sociale
veille à ce que ces associations
puissent accomplir leur action et que ce
soit plutôt des fonds neutres des fonds
d'État des fonds provenant de la SC
sociale que des fonds provenant des
laboratoires et je suis très inquiet
quand je vois par exemple que
l'Association française pour le pour le
diabète et bien euh reçoit euh des
laboratoires chaque année
649930 € quoi c'est c'est évidemment
beaucoup c'est sans doute nécessaire à
son fonctionnement mais je crois que ça
porte quand même atteinte à son
indépendance quand il s'agit de euh
porter un jugement sur la qualité euh
des des euh de l'éducation des
conditions de dans lesquelles sont mené
et mener l'éducation thérapeutique c'est
la raison pour laquelle euh je voterai
nous voterons contre cet amendement
madame la
ministre là encore il y a une très
grande confusion il s'agit absolument
pas de de l'évaluation des financements
ENF je je je ça n'a rien à voir avec
l'amendement vous donnez une une raison
vraiment je excusez-moi de vous dire
vous mettez rarement côté de la à côté
de la plaque je suis souvent pas
d'accord avec vous mais au moins vous
répondez à la question posée là ça n'a
vraiment rien à voir je parle des
programmes d'éducation thérapeutique et
de leur pertinent il va y avoir avec ces
le concept d'éducation thérapeutique des
des centaines des milliers des dizaines
de milliers de programmes d'éducation
thérapeutique puisque nous sommes dans
une démarche personnalisée la question
c'est de savoir qui est-ce qui va
évaluer la pertinence de ces programmes
d'éducation thérapeutique est-ce qu'ils
sont adaptés au cahier des charges
nationales aux bonnes pratiques à
l'adaptation à la personnalisation et
cetera alors alors je comprends bien la
vie de de monsieur le rapporteur et qui
reconnaît évidemment le rôle éminent
d'expertice de la Haute Autorité de
Santé est-ce que véritablement
raisonnablement mesdames les sénatrices
messieurs les sénateurs on peut faire
remonter à la Haute Autorité de Santé la
dizaine les dizaines de milliers de
programmes d'éducation thérapeutique que
que qu'elle aurait à évaluer alors je je
comprends bien la démarche
intellectuelle du rapporteur mais là
encore je vous demande d'avoir une
démarche pragmatique ce que je propose
c'est de faire cette évaluation au
niveau de la RS d'ailleurs pour
permettre de de constater puisque je
veux une démarche pluridisciplinaire
dans ces programmes d'éducation
thérapeutique je veux que cette
évaluation elle est lieu au niveau de
l'adaptation de l'agence régionale de
santé mais je sais bien que l'agence
régionale de santé elle a besoin autant
qu'il sera nécessaire d'une instance qui
va réunir ses capacités d'expertise au
niveau national et qui sera pour elle
une sorte de centre de ressources vous
comprenez ma démarche Haute Autorité de
Santé
afsaps inpè pour pouvoir prendre en
compte les différents éléments d'une
démarche d'éducation thérapeutique moi
ce que je veux c'est avoir une approche
pragmatique et et et
véritablement si vous voulez bien
reconsidérer les choses euh n'ayons pas
une démarche come dirais-je trop
théoricienne je pense que vraiment la
démarche que je vous propose celle qui
n'embourbera pas la hasas et qui
permettra d'évaluer une démarche
personnalisée adaptée au
terrain bien chers collègues plus
personne monsieur le président de la
commission des affaires
sociales monsieur le Président indiquer
à mes collèg que on ne parle pas des de
la même
chose dans un cas il y a P qui établit
un cahier de décharg national et qui
aura à vérifier à la demande des ARS si
ce qui est fait au niveau local le
programme à partir de ce cahier national
est bien conforme au cahier
national on peut se demander de
l'utilité de la mesure j'ai pas très
bien compris mais enfin c'est
certainement important de réunir tout un
comité de C toute cette non mais c'est
important de mettre en place cette
énorme commission qui réunit donc trois
trois structures pour se prononcer sur
la confor é à la demande de l'ARS de
certains de certains programmes mis en
place par ses ARS au niveau local ça
voudrait dire que Laars est même pas
capable de faire un truc qui soit
conforme au cahier national qu'on lui a
donné mis en place par l'INP donc je je
sais je pense que c'est certainement une
voie de recours oui de de la part de la
RS qui met en place donc ce qu'on peut
lui demander c'est surtout de veiller à
se mettre en place des choses qui soient
conformes mais éviter de créer un
recours contre lui-même puisque que
c'est lui qui le mettra en place donc
s'il peut éventuellement voir ça avant
et là par contre il est question de
permettre à la Haute Autorité de Santé
d'évaluer l'impact thérapeutique
l'avantage thérapeutique de ces
programmes bien sûr qu'il va pas
prendre les milliers de programmes avec
sa petite main puis commencer à faire
ses évaluations il va s'appuyer sur les
évaluations des ARS mais compilé au
niveau national et en sortir en dégager
des conclusions très intéressantes et
pour savoir s'il y a lieu de poursuivre
dans telle ou telle direction ou au
contraire de de modifier les choses donc
je trouve que l'autorité de santé la
Haute Autorité paraissait la mieux
choisie d'autant plus que on nous a
madame la ministre a insisté beaucoup
pour nous dire que l'éducation
thérapeutique ne faisait pas partie de
l'éducation pour la santé et que là on
est dans on est dans un autre domaine ça
n'est pas de la formation de de de la
formation on est véritablement là au
niveau du de l'impact du médicament des
des protocoles mis en place et qui mieux
que la Haute Autorité de santé peut
effectivement nous guider dans
l'évaluation de tous ces
programs bien bon si plus personne ne
demande la parole je mets au voix
l'amendement
1265 du gouvernement que ceux qui sont
d'avis d'adopt veuillent bien le
manifester en levant la
main avis
contraire allez l'amendement n'est pas
adopté
nous poursuivons toujours à l'article 22
un
amendement
896 rectifié de Monsieur Desessard
oui monsieur le Président c'est avec
plaisir que je vais défendre
l'amendement présenté par Monsieur
Antoinette patient Gillot larch lise tua
monsieur Antoinette ne peut pas être là
car il é obligé de partir en guyan je
crois qu'il y a des élections dimanche
prochain mais si nous le savons nous en
débattons mais si on avait eu une petite
semaine de vacances parlementaires ça
nous aurait permis de faire campagne et
de pouvoir expliquer en quoi l'Europe
est importante dans lere travail de tous
les jours hein et dans nos délibérations
mais j'ai encore pas compris monsieur
Desessard pour qui vous faisiez campagne
d'ailleurs bien j'aurais eu plaisir à
parler Europe euh effectivement cette
dernière semaine avec l'ensemble des
citoyens mais bon je parle de la loi
Hôpital avec madame la ministre monsieur
le rapporteur vous mes chers
collègues donc je par cet amendement
monsieur Antoinette propose et moi-même
donc puisque je le défends de de
rajouter une phrase ainsi rédigée ce
cahier des charges nationales proposera
le cas échéant les adaptations utiles au
programme d'accompagnement devant tenir
compte de particularités locales
notamment dans les régions
département et collectivité
d'outremè je pense qu'on a débattu sur
la notion de spécificité le fait qu'il
soit utile de le reconnaître je pense
qu'il est inutile de d'en rajouter les
les enjeux ont été bien
compris quel est l'avis de la commission
monsieur le
rapporteur
oui monsieur le Président le cahier des
charge ne peut proposer les adaptations
pour chacune des actions
d'accompagnement par contre il prévoira
sans doute que les actions sont adaptées
au aux circonstances locales qui peuvent
influer sur les pathologies c'est
d'ailleurs le but des actions
d'accompagnement que d'être adapté aux
besoins des malades c'est donc un avis
défavorable le ministre je me suis déjà
expliqué donc défavorable trs bien allez
qui plus personne ne demande la parole
dans ce cas-là je mets au voix
l'amendement de Monsieur Desessard
896 rectifié que ceux qui sont d'avide
adopté voz bien le manifestant en levir
la
main merci habit
contraire ah voilà alors l'amandem n
pase adopté euh amendement 689 juste
hein encore à une voix après qu'est-ce
que voulez faire c'est l'amendement
c'est pas l'amendement des Essards c'est
l'amendement
ballon pour la pu du vin il faut qu même
Valon c'est c'est c'est très important
dans
l'histoire voilà il y a même son buste
là dans le
couloir bon alors attendez on poursuit
689 rectifié toujours de Monsieur
desessar mais oui monsieur le Président
il se trouve que Monsieur Antoinette ne
peut pas défendre l'amendement que je
vais vous présenter maintenant parce que
je pense qu'il étaé obligé de retourner
en Guyane parce qu'il était il y a des
élections dimanche prochain donc je suis
obligé de le présenter
l'amendement l'amendement ainsi
rédigé les fonctions de médiateur en
santé publique et de médiateur en santé
mobilisé dans les programmes
d'accompagnement seront conformes à un
référentiel de métier de formation
permettant d'encadrer l'étendu et les
limites des missions de ces intervenants
et d'accorder à ces derniers un statut
équitable au sein des personnels des
établissements de santé des associations
des ONG et de tous autres organismes
intervenant dans le champ de l'éducation
thérapeutique du patient voici la
l'alinéa que nous souhaitons rajouter au
texte en effet au titre 4 du projet de
loi l'article L 11711 du Code de Santé
Publique annonce je cite que les
compétences nécessaires pour dispenser
l'éducation thérapeutique du patient
sont déterminé par décret un peu plus
plus loin l'article L
11613 déclare que les actions
d'accompagnement font partie de
l'éducation thérapeutique elles ont pour
objet d'apporter une assistance et un
soutien au malad ou à leur entourage
dans la prise en charge de la maladie au
vu de contenu de du contenu de ces Artic
je souhaite m'assurer car cela revê une
importance capitale pour la Guyane mais
et je le sais pour beaucoup d'autres
territoires de la métropole d'une part
que les compétences de médiateur de
santé et de santé publique ne seront pas
oublié dans le décret et d'autre part
que ces fonctions obtiendront enfin
peut-être grâce à cette loi ou au décret
qui découleront une reconnaissance
institutionnelle et un statut clair je
m'explique les actions de prévention de
promotion de la santé d'éducation pour
la santé d'accompagnement du patient
mobilise dans certains territoires et
pour certaines population des
compétences spécifiques induites par la
nécessaire prise en compte des citoyens
des situations socio-économique mais
également linguistique linguistique et
culturel des populations des patients
c'est en tout cas fortement le cas en
Guyane où l'on a parfois besoin d'une
pédagogie particulière s'appuyant sur la
compréhension de la culture du patient
pour amener ce dernier à comprendre et
accepter son traitement changer son
comportement ou ses habitude de vie dans
ce cas le rôle du médiateur est
incontournable je parle évidemment de la
Guyane mais cela pourrait être vrai dans
chaque territoire de l'Hexagone hein
ou dans les zones à forte population de
migrants or alors que depuis 98 ces
compétences sont mobilisées dans de
nombreux établissements hospitaliers
dispensaires association que des
expériences de formation se sont
développées y compris à un niveau
universitaire en Guyane c'est l'imea qui
a assuré cette formation pour pour
contribuer à la professionnalisation de
ces métiers assurés parfois par des
personnes formées à bac+ 3 ces fonctions
n'ont toujours pas reçu une
reconnaissance
institutionnelle le financement des
postes de médiateur est essentiellement
assuré aujourd'hui par les fonds de la
politique de la ville dans le casadre du
dispositif adulte relais pour une
rémunération équivalent à 75 % du SMIC
soit moins de 1000 € mensuels et pour
des durées toujours précaire je pense
qu'aujourd'hui alors qu'une loi consacre
un tit à l'éducation thérapeutique il
est temps de sécuriser l'exercice de ses
missions clarifier et régulariser ses
fonctions et ses personnels leur donner
un statut clair au sein des équipes dans
lesquelles ils exercent le présent
amendement vise donc la sécurisation
l'encadrement et la reconnaissance des
fonctions de médiation en santé et en
santé publique dans le domaine de
l'éducation thérapeutique notamment dans
l'accompagnement en tant que maillon
désormais indispensable de la chaîne des
acteurs entourant et accompagnant les
patients dans certains territoires je
vous remercie monsieur le Président et
chers collègues vous êtes sûr que vous
nous avez tout dit
bien
alors l'avis de la commission monsieur
le rapporteur
ou bon je vais
donc bien monsieur le Président les
médiateurs en santé publique nintervi
pas que pour l'éducation thérapeutique
la question de leur statut est donc plus
large elle ne peut être réglée à
l'occasion de cet article c'est un avis
défavorableouver madame la ministre oui
défavorable non pas que le le le rôle de
médiateur ne soit pas important monsieur
Desessard c'est effectivement et en
particulier pour des populations
précaires et fragilisées des éléments
très importants il y a des acteurs
extrêmement différents de formation très
diversifié qui interviennent dans ce
rôle de médiation en santé médiation
santé publique mais il ne revient pas
euh au travers d'un texte sur
l'éducation thérapeutique de créer un
nouveau métier qui demanderait
d'ailleurs un travail d'expertise de
concertation de définition du contour du
métier de la formation euh le le ce que
vous indiquez dans votre amendement ne
peut recueillir un avis favorable de ma
part monsieur Vassel a demandé la
paroleésident appel au
règlement monsieur le Président cela va
fera pour la fin de la semaine près de 6
semaines que nous sommes sur ce texte y
compris le temps consacré par la
commission nous travaillons nous avons
travaillé hier au rythme de 15
amendements à l'heure nous travaillons
depuis ce matin autour de 10 11
amendements à l'heure j'ai regardé le
nombre d'amendements qui nous reste à
examiner dont deux points extrêmement
importants sur lequels nous restons nous
risquons de nous attarder longuement
j'ai calculé que nous terminerons si
terminer le texte pas avant 7h du matin
ça aller travailler en continu s'il n'y
a pas un effort de concision dans la
réponse du gouvernement dans l'exposé
des motifs je vois que nos collègues se
contentent pas de donner les éléments de
l'exposé des motifs qui est dans
l'amendement mais souvent nous présente
un exposé dectif qui va bien au-delà de
ce qui est écrit dans le texte moi je
souhaite je fais un appel à la concision
sinon vous risquez monsieur le Président
d'avoir un hémicycle qui risque de se
vider au f à mesure que les vont passer
donc le président et le bureau du Sénat
appréciera avec le gouvernement la suite
à donner mais je suis assez préoccupé de
la tournure des
événements bon allez mes chers collègues
je mets au voix l'amendement 689
rectifié de notre collègue monsieur
Desessard que ceux qui sont avis
d'adopter veuilleent bien le manifester
en levant la
main j'ai déjà commc le vote monsieur
Desessard c'est limite allez allez
allez-y si vous voulez mais c'est
limite allez allez
oui mais c'est toujours désagréable de
s'entendre dire ça monsieur Vassel après
qu'on a présenté un amendement je dois
dire que j'ai présenté un amendement
auquel tenait un certain nombre de
personnes qui ont travaillé faut dire
que dans l'organisation ils avaiit prévu
et à plusieurs reprises monsieur
Antoinette est venu ici a attendu pour
pour présenter ses amendements et
effectivement le fait qu'on ait aucune
vision dans l'organisation des débats
sur à quel moment va passer un
amendement rend très difficile le fait
de pouvoir avoir des activités autres en
particulier à 3 jours des élections et
le fait de pouvoir participer au débat
donc ce que vous dites monsieur Vassel
je veux bien l'entendre effectivement
faire un effort par rapport à
l'organisation des débats jusqu'à demain
matin mais il faut aussi que la
présidence et l'ensemble des des
personnes qui organise le débat soit un
peu plus rigoureux pour que nous
parlementaires nous puissions nous
organiser mais maintenant cela n'enlève
à rien hein au travail à
l'investissement qu'on fait le
rapporteur madame la ministre le
président de la commission et l'ensemble
des personnes qui ont assisté au débat
depuis le début mais ce n'est pas parce
que vous avez passé beaucoup de temps
qu'il faut pas réfléchir au fait qu'on
pourrait mener les débat de façon
différente euh pour l'instant nous
allons procéder au vote du 689 rectifié
de Monsieur des essard que ceux qui sont
d'avis d'adopt veuillez bien le
manifester en levant la
main avis
contraire l'amendement n'est pas adopté
toujours après l'article 22 alors un
amendement du Gouvernement 1266 madame
la ministre je veux par cet amendement
faire que les entreprises qui mettent
sur le marché des médicaments les
dispositifs médicaux les les dispositif
médicaux diagnostic invitro puisse
participer à l'élaboration à la mise en
œuvre des programmes d'éducation
thérapeutique si des professionnels de
santé ou des associations agréant sont
les promoteurs et cette participation
doit inclure la possibilité de
cofinancement dans le respect du cahier
des chares national des règles de
transparence et d'évaluation ces
entreprises en revanche ne doivent pas
avoir de contact direct avec les
patients leur entourage ou leurs
représentants légaux pour les les
raisons éthiques et déontologi dont nous
avons déjà parlé l'avis de la commission
monsieur le rapporteur monsieur le
Président la Commission a choisi d'être
réaliste de préserver en l'état actuel
la possibilité de financement dans le
cadre de programme d'apprentissage donc
c'est une sagesse plutôt positive et le
556 de Monsieur hatin
oui monsieur le Président Madame le
ministre mes chers collègues les
programmes d'éducation thérapeutique
ou d'accompagnement doivent sous aucun
prétexte permettre à des fabricants ou à
des personnes responsables de la mise
sur le marché de produit de rentrer en
contact avec les patients participants
au programme le fait qu'il leur soit
possible de le faire lorsque les
professionnels de santé et les
associations de santé élaborent et
mettent en œuvre ce programme ne
constitue en rien un gardefou comme le
rappelle Ligas dans son rapport ces
associations sont la plupart du temps
créées par les laboratoires eux-mêmes on
en a déjà parlé je n'y reviens pas ces
associations peuvent être même parfois
quasi exclusivement financé par
l'industrie je citais tout à l'heure
l'exemple de l'AFD qui touche des sommes
très importante comme je l'indiquais à
l'instant protéger les patients en
empêchant l'industrie de rentrer en
contact avec eux est une recommandation
très pressente de Ligas nous en avons
déjà parlé c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous déposons cet
amendement monsieur le rapporteur l'avis
sur l'amendement de Monsieur haain
monsieur le Président la participation
des entreprises est nécessaire et la
phrase que l'amendement souhaite
supprimer permet d'encadrer cette
participation donc c'est un avis
défavorable du gouvernement sur cet
amendement même avis plus personne ne
demande la parole dans ce cas-là je mets
au voix l'amendement
1266 du gouvernement que ceux qui sont
d'avis d'adopter veuill bien manifester
en la main merci avis contraire
l'amendement est adopté alors et l'autre
de Monsieur hatin
tombe s'il tombe vous voulez parler
monsieur hatin ben rapidement alors
peut-être ben oui parce que c'est une
faveur si le bureau du Sénat n'a pas
prévu le temps
nécessaire à des débats qui sont
absolument
indispensables mois ben 6 semaines oui
mais enfin c'est l'application d'une
réforme c'est oui mais enfin je suis
perturbé là monsieur le Président par
les intervention int avec votre
ancienneeté parlementaire vous ne pouvez
être perturbé que par le charme de celle
qui vous
interpelle bon alors monsieur le
Président simplement je voulais euh
donner les raisons pour lesquelles on
pouvait on ne pouvait pas être d'accord
sur l'amendement précédent pour lequel
j'ai voté contre très la rapidité avec
laquelle vous avez demandé le vote et
alors que j'avais levé la main ne m'a
pas permis alors pour je me retranche en
l'occurrence pour expliquer mon B
derrière un communiqué de presse du
collège de la Haute Autorité de santé
dont on ne peut pas critiquer hein
l'impartialité voilà ce que disait ce
communiqué de presse du collège de la
Haute Autorité de santé à l'occasion des
débats autour de l'hôpital santé
patients et territoire le collège de la
Haute Autorité de Santé rappelle
l'importance des enjeux de l'éducation
thérapeutique et des actions
d'accompagnement dans la prise en charge
des patients la distinction figurant
dans le projet de loi entre éducation
thérapeutique action d'accompagnement et
programme d'apprentissage contribu à la
nécessaire clarification de ces notions
différentes au-delà de cette
clarification il importe de veiller à ce
que l'approche des actions d'éducation
thérapeutique et d'accompagnement ne
soit pas trop orienté vers la seule
observance médicamenteuse orientation
qui serait renforcée si la possibilité é
ouverte aux industriels du médicament de
financer directement ou indirectement de
telles actions qu'elles soi mise en
œuvre par des professionnels de santé ou
des associations de patients cette
possibilité j'insiste je cite risquerait
de rendre les acteurs concernés
dépendant de cette source de cette de
cette source de financement voilà les
raisons pour lesquelles en m'appuyant
sur ce communiqué de presse du collège
de la Haute Autorité de santé dont on
connaît l'indépendance que je j'ai
déposé cet amendement et j'ai voté pour
l'amendement présenté par Madame la
Ministre tout à l'heure poursuivant dans
l'examen des amendements l'amendement
900 Monsieur dodini Merci monsieur le
Président Madame la Ministre mes chers
collègues par cet amendement nous
souhaitons un renforcement de
l'encadrement des programmes
d'apprentissage qui ont pour objet
l'appropriation d'un geste technique
permettant l'utilisation d'un médicament
et ceci afin d'éviter toute dérivve
promotionnelle à cette fin donc cet
amendement propose que les conditions
d'éligibilité à ces programmes
d'apprentissage soient restreintes aux
médicaments pour lesquels il n'y a pas
d'alternative d'administration plus aisé
pour les patients ce qui implique que
leur usage est particulièrement complexe
et que ces médicaments correspondent à
des progrès thérapeutiques majeurs que
la direction de l'fsaps compétente pour
évaluer les programmes d'apprentissage
soit identifieré précisément au fin que
l'autorisation octroyée repose sur des
critères d'évaluation robuste et adaptée
que la Haute Autorité de Santé et
l'Institut national de prévention
d'éducation pour la santé qui joue un
rôle non négligeable dans l'information
du grand public soit consulté sur ces
programmes d'apprentissage qu'il soit a
précisé dans la loi que les médecins qui
orientent des patients dans des
programmes d'apprentissage ne soient pas
rémunérés financièrement ou en nature
par les laboratoire
pharmaceutique alors nous pour alors le
655 rectifié tombe aucun sénateur
présent ne peut le défendre le
gouvernement
1267 amendement du Gouvernement madame
la ministre
oui le souhait de de mettre en œuvre des
programmes d'apprentissage pour les
seuls médicaments résulte d'un rapport
de Ligas longuement évoqué par ailleurs
de décembre 2007 liigas qui avait été
missionné pour définir les futures
dispositions en matière d'encadrement
des programmes d'accompagnement des
patients associés à un traitement
médicamenteux et financé par les
entreprises pharmaceutiques et il le le
domaine des dispositifs médicaux ne
répond pas au mêm critères d'encadrement
que celui du médicament il repose sur le
marquage CE que vous connaissez
garantissant sa confor é aux exigences
essentielles de sécurité et de santé une
fois ce dispositif enfin ce ce marquage
obtenu un dispositif médical peut être
librement commercialisé sur l'ensemble
du territoire de l'Union Européenne en
outre le rattachement des dispositifs
médicau au programme d'apprentissage ne
serait pas en adéquation sur le plan
communautaire avec le principe de
j'ouvre les guillemets nouvelle approche
fermé les guillemets qui repose sur une
responsabilisation accrue du fabricantz
les fabricants et les prestataires de
dispositifs médicaux ont déjà un rôle
privilégié en matière d'apprentissage et
d'assistance pour leur bonne utilisation
la seconde partie de l'amendement vise à
supprimer toute référence à
l'accréditation par lafsaps des
promoteurs de programmes d'apprentissage
en effet charger lafsaps de mettre en
œuvre une telle accréditation alors
qu'elle est déjà responsable de de
délivrer une autorisation compliquerait
alourdirait le dispositif sans avantage
notable c'est pourquoi il est proposé de
prévoir un décret d'application dans
lequel un audit effectué par un tier
indépendants sera mis en place et ses
résultats communiqués à la saaps et
c'est un amendement un peu technique
mais très opérationnel que je vous prie
de bien vouloir
accepter alors nous poursuivons par un
amendement
522 de Monsieur
hatin oui cet amendement est la
traduction d'une préconisation de Ligas
qui après avoir pu constater que les
programmes dit d'observance ou
d'accompagnement soumis à l'Agence
Française des produits de santé sont
pour l'essentiel guidés par des
considérations économiques et rarement
par des raisons médicales et rappelle
que c'est rappelle que c'est l'intérêt
des patients qui doit
primer merci Monsieur tin le 221
rectifié monsieur Gautier monsieur non
c'est monsieur girud Adrien girud
monsieur girud sur le 221
rectifié monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre l'objet de cet amendement est
de préciser que par priorité la
formation des patients devant apprendre
les gestes techniques permettant
l'utilisation des médicaments déterminés
incombe au personnel de santé ayant la
charge du 10 patient
le
521 et monsieur le Président ficher
alors si vous voulez bien monsieur le
Président je peux faire le 525 pour vous
faire
plaisir c'était le 523 vous le sauter
celui-là non mais c'est François ça
c'est François très bien alorsit faites
les deux monsieur le Président ne vous
en privez pas alors ces amendements
s'inscrivent dans une logique de
transparence séparation claire entre des
activités commerciales lucratives et la
participation à des programmes
d'éducation thérapeutique dont les
intéress sont nécessairement ceux des
malades et en effet nous proposons que
la personne qui intervient pour le
compte de l'entreprise ayant
commercialisé le produit faisant l'objet
d'éducation thérapeutique ne puisse pas
pouvoir en tirer ou de sa rémunération
de base d'autres revenus ou quelques
avantages qu'il soit notamment en
il s'agit pour être clair d'interdire la
rémunération et la gratification du
professionnel de santé ou de l'éducateur
qui organise l'éducation thérapeutique
par les laboratoires pharmaceutiques une
une rémunération dont on devine qu'elle
serait fondé sur des critères
quantitatifs qui n'ont pas lieu d'être
en la matière il nous a semblé qu'un
large consensus sétait dégagé sur l'idée
que l'éducation thérapeutique était à la
fois un acte de la Contin et un acte et
la continuité des soins al c'est pour
cela que si nous sommes d'accord il faut
en tirer toutes les conséquen et c'est
ce que nous enons faisons avec cet
amendement en proposant que de préciser
que la participation des professionnels
et des éducateurs ne peut se faire que
sur la base du volontariat et ne peut
donner lieu à une autre forme de
rémunération ou
d'intéressement merci monsieur le
Président fichè alors 523 de Monsieur
hatin il est défendu hein vous
voyez très bien euh ne non provoquez pas
non plus euh qu'est-ce qu'il veut le
président de la commission des affaires
sociales si vous l'acceptter Président
je reprends l'amendement de Monsieur
mard à mon compte cet amendement précise
que le programme d'apprentissage ne peut
donner lieu à des avantage financier ou
en natures bien le 647 rectifié très
bien
524 toujours de Monsieur
hatin amendement nous entendons préciser
que le médecin prescripteur des actions
thérapeutiques ne doit pas communiquer
les données recueillies pour établir ses
prescriptions cette précision est
d'autant plus importante que l'opérateur
intervient pour être missionné et
financé par l'entreprise thérapeutique
commercialisant le médicament
concerné essayez pas monsieur hatin
526 et
merci hein ou une
embolie alors selon un récent un récent
article du British medéical
Journal au Royaume-Uni la firme Roche
offre des bons d'achat de 10 livr
sterling aux malades atteint de la
mucovicidose en échange de 30 ampoules
vides
de pulmosime médicament qu'elle
commercialise pour le traitement de
cette maladie inscrire le principe de
l'interdiction de la rémunération des
patients et de leur entourage pour leur
participation à un programme
d'apprentissage et dè l'ORS nécessaires
pour éviter des dérives client liste tel
est le sens de cet amendement amendement
527 monsieur le Président si vous
permettez cet amendement s'inscrit dans
une dans une volonté de transparence en
rendant publies les décisions et
sanctions mis en œuvre par les autorités
sanitaires il vise à comp à compléter la
rédaction proposée par cet article 22
pour l'article
l161-5 du code de la santé publique et
plus particulièrement son dernier alinéa
qui traite de l'arrêt des actions mises
en place dans le cadre des programmes
d'apprentissage en effet il est prévu
que je cite si les programmes
d'apprentissage ne respecte pas les
dispositions d'autorisation euh
ù sont mis en œuvre par par des
personnes n'ayant pastenu
l'accréditation l'agence retire
l'autorisation et le cas échéant ordonne
l'arrê immédat des actions mises en
place fin de citation notre amendement
complète donc la disposition actuelle en
prévoyant que l'agence diffuse sans
délai un message d'alerte au médecins
prescripteurs et aux patients engagés
dans le programme incriminé afin de les
informer de la situation et faire dans
les plus brefs délis un programme qui
pourrait éventuellement
représenter des risques pour les
patients nous posons également que
l'agence rende publique sa décision son
message d'alerte et les sanctions
appliquées en au contevenant afin que
l'ensemble des acteurs notamment ceux
qui ne sont pas actuellement impliqués
dans un programme je pense
particulièrement ici au professionnels
alors direz-vous l'amendement que nous
proposons va de soi il n'en demeure pas
moins que parfois cela va mieux en le
prévoyant explicitement voilà pourquoi
nous vous proposons cet amendement merci
Monsieur monsieur le rapporteur alors
nous prenons tous les amendements dans
l'ordre commencer par le
1267 non je commence par le 900
président ah le 900 oui oui tout à fait
par le 900 le 900 donc présenté par le
groupe socialiste mon chers collègue il
n'est pas nécessaire d'avoir l'avis de
la Haute Autorité de santé et de
l'impesse sur la mise en œuvre de
programme liés au médicaments de plus
lafsaps a déjà dû évaluer le mode
d'administration lors de l'autorisation
de la mise sur le marché il sera donné
satisfaction à la volonté d'interdire
les avantages financiers en nature tant
pour les médecins que pour les malades
et leur entourage par un autre
amendement enfin la commission
compétente de lafsaps sera déterminée
par décret de même que l'ensemble de la
procédure c'est donc un avis
défavorable 267 l'amendement du
Gouvernement en matière de programme
d'apprentissage de nombreuses
prestations privées interviennent pour
le compte de l'industrie pharmaceutique
leur accréditation permettrait de
garantir leur éthique et simplifiera
l'examen de demande d'autorisation c'est
donc une sagesse
positive du groupe CRC SPG mon cher
collègue le médecin prescripteur a déjà
déterminé quels sont les choix
thérapeutiques les plus favorables au
patients avant de lui proposer
d'intégrer un programme c'est donc un
avis défavorable 221 rectifié la
commission a émis un avis favorable à
l'amendement rectifié qui prévoit que
les programmes d'apprentissage doivent
être inclus dans la formation continue
des professionnels de santé peut-être
les entreprises seront-elles sensibles à
cette priorité indiquée par le Sénat je
voudrais ajouter et je regrette que
Monsieur des cessard soit parti faire
une campagne pour les élections
européennes mais ajouter que cet
amendement a été a été proposé par notre
collègue Adrien girud sénateur de
Mayotte qui lui est présent pour
présenter les amendements merci Monsieur
GIR allez 523 le 521 21 21 521 du groupe
CRC SPG c'est un avis défavorable les
personnes qui mettent en uvre les
programmes sont souvent employés par des
prestataires et pas par l'entreprise
directement on ne peut on ne peut dès
lors leur interdire un but
lucratif le 523 c'est un avis
défavorable par cohérence monsieur le
Président le
525 amendement qui interdit les
rémunérations et les contreparties en
nature la diretion est trop large et
interdirait même la possibilité pour le
médecin de bénéficier du programme ou
des études conduites à cette occasion
c'est donc un avis défavorable le 647
présenté par le président Abou c'est un
avis de sagesse
positive le
524 du groupe
crcspg le médecin mes chers collègues
est déjà astreint au secret
professionnel on voit mal quelles sont
les données recueillies auxquelles il
est fait référence c'est donc un avis
défavorable le
526 il est satisfait par le 647 si le
647 est adopté et le 527 le dispositif
est prévu par l'article est suffisant
c'est donc un avis défavorable bien
alors nous allons écouter l'avis du
Gouvernement sauf sur l'amendement 1267
déjà présenté sur les autres amendement
madame le ministre alors sur
l'amendement 900 j'ai un avis
défavorable pour les mêmes raisons que
Monsieur le le rapporteur sur
l'amendement 522
euh effectivement un avis
défavorable c'est une précision inutile
le bien fondé de la prescription tient
compte évidemment de de l'existence
d'alternative thérapeutique plus
favorable et et tout cela est de la
responsabilité du médecin prescripteur
relève des bonnes pratiques médicales et
du bon usage des
médicaments l'amendement défendu par
Monsieur girud alors je comprends bien
l'idée que vous avez défendu monsieur
Atur mais
euh c'est c'est un amendement qui
soulève un certain nombre de difficultés
c'est pour ça que je vous demanderai
plutôt de de le retirer parce que le
texte issu de la Commission prévoit que
des opérateurs association de patients
mutuelles à la demande de laboratoire
pharmaceutique ou de leur propre
initiative forment des professionnels de
santé qui à leur tour forment les
patients auou gestes technique c'est
donc le médecin prescripteur qui propose
le programme d'apprentissage à son
patient et qui l'oriente vers
l'opérateur la mise en œuvre du
programme est en subordonné au
consentement écrit du patient
l'autorisation et le contrôle de ces
programmes d'apprentissage et et sont
confiés à à la à lafsaps votre
amendement propose que ce soit par
priorité les professionnels de santé en
charge du patient qui assurent
directement la formation de leur propre
patient si c'était le cas la formation
de ces professionnels pourrait ainsi ne
pas être encadrée par un opérateur et
pourrait se faire en dehors de tout
programme autorisé et contrôlé par
l'agence cela pourrait également
conduire à une hétérogénéité de la
formation des patients par ailleurs ces
professionnels de santé qui formeraient
leurs propres patients pourrait alors
être rémunéré pour cette formation ce
qui entraînerait une confusion des rôles
et soulèverait des risques de conflit
d'intérêts alors je comprends bien
l'idée mais vous voyez que la démarche
éthique pour à ce moment-là être
perturbée et il vaut mieux différencier
les choses et c'est la raison pour
laquelle je je demanderais le retrait de
cet amendement euh je suis défavorable
au 521 pour les mêmes raisons que le
rapporteur ainsi qu'au 523 euh
ou 525 je je je je rappelle d'ailleurs
euh que il y a beaucoup de précisions
qui sont totalement inutiles il y a déjà
très clairement dans le code de la santé
publique à l'article
4113-6 une disposition qui interdit aux
membres des profession médicale de
recevoir des avantages en nature ou en
espèce par les entreprises de prestation
produits ou dispositif de santé pris en
charge par la Sécurité Sociale donc il y
a toutes sortes d'amendements qui
répètent ce cette disposition et c'est
le cas du 647 rectifié qui a été repris
par le rapporteur c'est une précision
totalement inutile elle est elle est
incluse d'ors et déjà dans le code de la
santé publique donc véritablement c'est
pas la peine de le répéter c'est c'est
tout à fait inclus respect de la
confidentialité je suis absolument
d'accord avec la raison qu'a donné le
rapporteur le
526 la rémunération du patient est bien
entendu défavorable non pas que je sois
en désaccord avec le fait qu'il faille
que le parent le patient ne soit pas
rémunéré euh et et l'agence évidemment
lafsaps pourra s'assurer lorsqu'elle
délivre l'autorisation de ses programmes
que ces programme comporte une clause
mentionnant l'interdiction de toute
rémunération versée aux patient euh 527
rendre publuique les décisions et
sanctions mises en œuvre par l'fsaps
avis défavorable c'est une disposition
de niveau réglementaire voilà j'ai donc
donné l'ensemble de de mes avis merci
madame la ministre monsieur girud est-ce
que vous êtes convaincu par les
arguments de la ministre est-ce que vous
retirez votre amendement comme elle vous
l'a demander
oui monsieur le Président retirer cet
amendement pour ne pas rallonger le la
discussion de la commission des affaires
sociales je pensais que l'amendement
était plus large puisqu'il couvrait
aussi les patients et leurs proches mais
bon
je sais pas je m'en remets à la sagesse
de notre
assemblée monsieur Hain pour explication
de
vote plus parce que j'ai l'impression
que madame la
ministre a répondu à un amendement que
je je ne me souviens pas avoir défendu
le
non oui je non non mais vous avez
anticipé non non mais comme j'avais pas
défendu ah bon je m'en suis pas
perçu je m'en suis pas perçu excusez-moi
très bien qui demande encore la parole
alors dans ce cas-là je mets au voix
dans l'ordre l'amendement 900 que ceux
qui sont d'avis de l'adopter veuillez
bien la manifester en levant la
main avis
contraire l'amendement n'est pas adopté
l'amendement du gouvernement 1267 que
ceux qui sont d'avis d'adopté veuillent
bien le manifester en levant la
main Bernadette ah voilà avis contraire
n'y a pas d'avis contraire l'amendement
est adopté il en est ainsi décidé
l'amendement
522 à deux avis contraires pardonnez-moi
j'avais pas vu le note ne vous inquiétez
pas l'amendement 522 de Monsieur hatin
et du président fichè que ceux qui sont
d'avis d'adopt veuillez bien le
manifester en levant la
main avis
contraire l'amendement n'est pas adopté
l'amendement de monsieur girud est
retiré 521 toujours de Monsieur hatin et
du président ficher que ceux qui sont
invis d'adopter veuilleent bien le
manifester en levant la main merci avis
contraire merci aussi l'amendement n'est
pas adopté
523 je consulte du regard la Haute
Assemblée même vote même
vote le
525 pareil je consulte du regard même
vote même vote il en est ainsi décidé
alors monsieur le président de la
commission des affaires sociales vous en
remettez à la sagesse dans ce cas-là je
mets au voix alors je mets au voix le
647 rectifié que ceux qui sont d'avis
d'adopt veuille bien le manifester en
levant la
main
bon avis contraire il y a pas d'avis
contraire alors allez l'amendement est
adopté le 524 de Monsieur hatin du
président ficher je mets au voix que
ceux qui sont d'avis d'adopter veuillez
bien le manifester en levir la main
merci avis
contraire merci aussi n'est pas adopté
le 526 même vote même vote pas
d'opposition il est aussi il n'est pas
adopté le 5 7 je consulte du regard la
Haute Assemblée il n'y a pas de même
vote même vote
ouis
voilà allez dans ce cas-là nous
poursuivons toujours après l'article 22
un amendement
1268 du gouvernement madame la ministre
oui c'est un amendement rédactionnel euh
qui renvoie un décret en Conseil d'État
les modalités d'application de l'article
sauf lorsque d'autres dispositions sont
prévues
explicitement en effet face aux enjeux
de de transparence d'éthique que requier
la mise en œuvre de ce dispositif de ces
dispositifs la régularité juridique au
regard du contexte administratif est
évidemment
indispensable
alors l'avis de la commission monsieur
le rapporteur favorable président très
bien qui demande la parole dans ce
cas-là je met au vo
l'amendement du Gouvernement que ceux
qui sont davisadopt veuilleent bien le
manifester en levant la main merci avis
contraire il n'y a pas d'avis contraire
la mar de Mar est adoptée il ainsi
décidé non je crois pas qu'il y en a un
derrière alors j'ai pas vu non non alors
après l'article 22 l'amendement 518 de
Monsieur
hatin j'en sur terrain
là
pardonnez-moi non non mais j'ai de toute
manière c'est pour vous aussi 557
rectifiés je le prends he allez c'est un
amendement rédactionnel
oui
ououi alors lequel je mets au voix là
j'y suis plus
celui-là non il expose celui-là il
exposé rédtionn de la commission alors
l'avis de la commission sur le 557
rectifier mon rapporteur président euh
généralement quand quand monsieur otin
dit rédactionnel on regarde de près on a
regardé de près et en effet c'est une
précision utile donc c'est un avis
favorable de la commission ah et l'avis
du Gouvernement madame la ministre je je
ne suis pas d'accord c'est pas une
précision utile elle est inutile euh les
régimes d'autorisation prévus par
l'article 22 seront mis en œuvre et
détaillé par décret en Conseil d'État
conformément à l'article
l161-6 donc c'est une précision inutile
monsieur le rapporteur alors néanmoins
je mets au voix l'amendement 500 57
rectifier que ceux qui sont d'avis
d'adopt veuillez bien le manifester en
levant la
main bon avis
contraire il est pas adopté il est
adopté et bien monsieur hatin voyez8
attendez et le
518 rectifié toujours de Monsieur
hatin finit par payer mais là je vais
être un peu plus long donc j'ai moins de
chance de le voir adopter
hein donc avec cet amendement nous
entendons une nouvelle fois sans doute
encore en vain revenir sur ce qui nous
apparaît être un manque important dans
ce projet de loi puisqu'il vise à
compléter la rédaction proposée pour
l'article l 1661-3 du code de la santé
publique qui crée une interdiction à
l'égard des entreprises pharmaceutiques
celle d'entreprendre tout contact direct
personnalisé en direction des patients
relatifs à un médicament prescrit une
interdiction qui pêche tout de même par
une faiblesse sa violation ne sera
jamais suivi de sanction puisque la loi
n'en prévoit pas c'est à croire que dans
le domaine de la santé le seul
fait le seul fait d'noncer une iction
suffit hlas n'est pas le cas et nous ne
le savons que trop c'est pourquoi nous
considérons que la loi doit prévoir une
sanction afin que cette interdiction est
réellement un caractère dissuasif c'est
pourquoi afin de donner toutes les
chances à cette disposition de
s'appliquer les auteurs de cet
amendement proposent l'instauration
d'une peine d'amende de 3500 € par
infraction constaté dont les modalités
d'application seront définies par
descé il me semble que cette somme est
tout à fait raisonnable au regard du
chiffre d'affaires des laboratoires
pharmaceutiques avec par conséquent il
serait me semble-t-il bon de
l'adopter de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur oui monsieur le Président
prévoir une sanction ça paraît cohérent
prévoir une sanction qui est assez
proportionnée ça paraît cohérent aussi
on va donner un avis de sagesse en
attendant l'avis du gouvernement alors
quel est l'avis du Gouvernement madame
la ministre bah je regrette cette cette
indulgence pour l'industrie
pharmaceutique auquelle ne m'avait pas
habitué monsieur ficher Monsieur Je je
je lis l'article
L161 et puni de 30000 € d'amende le fait
de mettre en œuvre un programme ou sans
une autorisation une accréditation
prévue aux articles pourquoi cette
générosité
soudaine je pense que là vous allez
retirer votre vous allez retirer votre
amendement dans la joie et la geté
là il y a eu
un enfin j'y suis tout à
faitorable Monsieur htin est-ce que vous
retirez votre amendement pour faire
plaisir à Madame la Ministre pour faire
plaisir à madame la ministre je retire
l' très bien très bien et bien dans ce
cas-là nous poursuivons toujours ne vous
rasseyez pas monsieur hatin
528 28 528
€ oui effectivement nous avons retiré
notre amendement tout à l'heure avec
nous n'aurions pas dû puisqueil
s'agissait pas des des mêmes infractions
enfin bon on y reviendra la prochaine
fois euh alors nous considérons qu'il
est important de rendre dissuasives les
sanctions du non respect des
autorisations relatives aux
actionsapprentissageacompagn thérapeu
petique c'est pourquoi nous proposons
d'augmenter le montant de l'amende prévu
initialement alors là
effectivement voilà alors là on peut pas
nous accuser d'avoir été soudoyés par
les laboratoires hein
effectivement alors monsieur le
rapporteur qu'est-ce qu'en pense la
Commission et vous-même elle a donné un
avis dever y en avait alors attendez
excusez-moi monsieur le rapporteur il y
a un amendement
1269 du gouvernement madame
ministre et bien euh j'ai j'ai déjà
d'ailleurs évoqué ces questions il
s'agit d'un amendement d'ordre
rédactionnel de mise en cohérence suite
à la
présentation pardon bah
oui
oui oui méfiance quand quelqu'un
présente un amendement rédactionnel mais
vous avouerez monsieur le rapporteur que
si cette méfiance est justifiée quand il
s'agit de Monsieur ficher ou de Monsieur
hatin elle est moins quand il s'agit du
gouvernement euh
euh c'est c'est effectivement
rappelez-vous de l'amendement
1267 demandant la suppression de
référence à l'accréditation par lafsaps
qui a d'ailleurs été accepté par votre
assemblée la mise en œuvre de tout un
dispositif d'accréditation par lafsaps
serait trop lourde et sans avantagees
supplémentairire donc l'amendement 1269
est dans la droite ligne du
1267 bien alors euh l'avis de la
commission monsieur le
rapporteur sur le 528 monsieur le
Président groupe crcspg euh c'est un
avis défavorable pour ce qui est de
l'amendement du Gouvernement je voudrais
juste dire à madame la ministre que en
effet la méfiance n'est jamais justifiée
et la la franchise et l'honnêteté ne
sont jamais mises en cause par contre
l'erreur est humaine donc il faut quand
même vérifier ce que ce que peut dire le
gouvernement
donc bah évidemment c'est pour ça que
nous avons bien regardé cet amendement
et mettons un avis de sagesse par
cohérence car il s'agit de supprimer
l'accréditation par
lasaps qui demande qui demande encore la
parole euh av oui sur le 528 madame la
ministre oui merci monsieur le Président
donc c'est un avis défavorable pour les
même raison que le rapporteur j'ajoute
ensuite que toute publication
deinfraction journal officielle euh est
évidemment cette précision est inutile
toute décision prononcée par le tribunal
judiciaire est évidemment
publique plus personne ne demande la
parole mes chers collègues dans ce
cas-là je mets au voix l'amendement 528
de Monsieur hautetin que ceux qui sont
d'avis d'adopter veuillez bien le
manifester en levir la main merci avis
contraire merci aussi n'est pas à
s'adopter l'amendement du Gouvernement
1269 que ceux qui sont David adopter
veille bien manifester en levant la
main avis
contraire l'amendement est adopté et en
est ainsi
décidé alors à l'article 22
1271 le c'est toujours la même chose
c'est toujours cet amendement
rédactionnel sur
l'accréditation très
bien le monsieur le
rapporteur c'est un avis de de favorable
évidemment je consulte du regard la
Haute Assemblée il n'y a pas
d'opposition s'il n'y a pas d'opposition
nous le considérons comme adopté arti
toujours après l'article 22 alors un
amendement
529 de Monsieur hatin
oui la dernière disposition de cet
article 22 prévoit que le gouvernement
déposera avant le 31 décembre 2010 un
rapport sur les conditions de mise en
œuvre de la création d'un fond nation
pour le développement de l'éducation
thérapeutique du patient une proposition
qui est en réalité la transposition dans
ce projet de loi des recommandation 19
et 20 du rapport pour une politique
nationale d'éducation thérapeutique du
patient qui vous a été remis Madame le
Ministre en septembre 2008 nous ne
sommes pas opposé évidemment à ce que
l'éducation thérapeutique du patient
puisse disposer de ressources
spécifiques notamment parce qu'un bon
usage de ces programmes pourrait avoir
des conséquences bénéfiques et pour les
comptes de la protection sociale et
c'est sans doute là le plus important
pour la santé et la qualité de vie des
patients qui en bénéficieraient
toutefois nous sommes opposés à la
création d'un fond supplémentaire qui
viendrait se rajouter à d'autres
structures c'est pourquoi nous
considérons dans un souci d'utilité et
de simplicité de clarté que l'Institut
national de prévention et l'éducation
pour la santé lin pè dans les missions
définies par la loi du 4 mars 2002 et
celle du 9 août 2004 prévoi que parmi
ces ces missions euh il y a celle
d'assurer le développement d'éducation
pour la santé sur l'ensemble du
territoire et d'établir les programmes
de formation à l'éducation à la santé
selon les modalités définies par décret
c'est pourquoi nous proposons qu'un
rapport soit effectivement remis mais
non plus sur la création d'un fond
spécifique dédié mais sur les conditions
de financement de l'Institut national de
prévention et d'éducation pour la santé
pour lui permettre de mettre en œuvre et
de développer l'action thérapeutique du
patient merci monsieur atin quel est
l'avis de la commission monsieur ah on
fait celui du gouvernement peut-être
alors avant si vous le permettez
pardonnez-moi
euh je veux par cet
amendement établir un rapport avant le
31 décembre 2010 sur la mise en œuvre de
l'éducation thérapeutique qui serait de
nature à satisfaire l'amendement
précédent y compris évidemment qui
aborderait la question de son finance
vous dans le texte que vous avez voté en
commission vous demandez qu'un rapport
soit présenté au Parlement sur la
création d'un fond national de
développement d'éducation thérapeutique
du patient nous en avons parlé
d'ailleurs dans dans les propos
liminires quand j'ai répondu sur sur
l'article aux différents intervenants
mais je trouve qu'il serait important de
compléter cette
thématique sur un éventuel fond dédié
par un état des lieux de la mise en
œuvre sur le terrain des programmes
d'éducation thérapeutique comme ça nous
pourrions faire dans le même rapport
euh répondre à toutes les questions le
Parlement serait ainsi clairement
informé sur la les modalités et la
montée en charge du dispositif dans ses
différentes composantes et je vous
propose d'élargir le champ de ce rapport
qui vous serait remis avant le 31
décembre
2010 merci Madame la Ministre alors
monsieur le rapporteur votre avis sur
les deux amendements alors le 529
monsieur le Président d'abord c'est un
avis déf en effet l'impess n'a pas
vocation à gérer les éventuels fonds à
louer àéducation thérapeutique de plus
sa compétence est partagée avec la aut
Autorité de Santé et lafsaps
l'amendement 1271 du gouvernement c'est
un amendement qui apporte des des
compléments utiles donc c'est un un avis
favorable sur le 529 madame la ministre
vous avez donné votre avis je peux faire
attention en creux monsieur le Président
je le reconnais donc un avis défavorable
je pense que l'amendement que je
présente va satisfaire la demande
d'information du Parlement de façon
complète alors monsieur haain va le
retirreer le 529
peut-être j'avais cru comprendre rere je
retire l'amendement très bien dans ce
cas-là je mets au voix l'amendement
1271 du gouvernement que ceux qui sont
Davis d'adopter veuilleent bien le
manifester en levant la
main merci avis contraire il y a pas
d'avis contraire l'amendement est adopté
il en est ainsi décidé voter sur
l'ensemble de l'article 2 alors il nous
reste à voter sur l'ensemble de
l'article 22 y y a-t-il des demandes de
parole non dans ce cas-là je mets au
voix que ceux qui sont d'Avid adopté
veuillez bien le manifester en levant la
main merci avit
contraire merci aussi l'amendement
l'article 22 est adopté allez après
l'article 22 bis une demande de parole
sur l'article 22 bis de Monsieur Gilbert
Barbier merci monsieur le Président mes
chers collègues Madame le Ministre
oui j'interviens sur ce 22 bis du projet
de loi parce que je solliciterai un vote
séparé sur cet article en dissociant le
paragraphe 2 bis nouveau même si la
totalité de l'article me paraît de
nature risquée par rapport aux tâches
qui pourrait être confié au sag-femme
frotti servicoutterrain consultation de
contraception suiv gynécologique de
prévention je pense que ces nouvelles
tâches nécessitent à tout le moins de
renforcer la formation initiale et
continue au-delà de l'obstétrique
compétenence traditionnelle et
ancestrale des chachoam de d'étendre
cette formation à la gynécologie qui est
une discipline à part après avoir
consulté le programme actuel de la
formation je suis inquiet sur ce nouveau
champ d'intervention qui leur est offert
par le présent projet de loi certes
s'agissant de la contraception et du
suivi gynécologique la compétence
exercera je cite sous réserve que la
sachefemme adresse la femme à un médecin
en cas de situation pathologique c'est
une belle phrase mais comment ne pas
trouver curieuse une telle rédaction de
cet Alen 2 du 2è Man en effet la
difficulté première est bien de détecter
cette situation pathologique la
formation des sages-femmes est-elle
suffisante pour leur le permettre cette
détection ne risque-t-elle pas de passer
à côté de prémises d'une pathologie
grave qui aurait pu avoir une évolution
heureuse précisément par une détection
précoce j'en viens aux deux bis qui
visent à autoriser la sachefemme à
pratiquer l'IVG par voie
médicamenteuse ce problème peut-être
abordé sous deux aspects le volet
éthique pour contre l'IVG chacun en
décide en âme et conscience est- le rô
de la sage-femme de proposer une IVG
chacun en jugera mais il y a le volet
technique si l'on peut dire parce que
l'IVG par le RU 486 la MIF et gine n'est
pas un acte tout à fait anodin mais une
section une succession d'actes obéissant
à l'heure actuelle à un protocole bien
défini
elle est tout aujourd'hui je reprends la
législation actuelle elle est
aujourd'hui autorisée par un gynécologue
ou un médecin général
travaillant en réseau avec un
établissement de santé avec lequel il a
pris convention elle est pratiquée avant
la fin de la 7e semaine c'est-à-dire à
la 5 maximum 5e semaine
d'aménoré avec une première consultation
au cours de laquelle le médecin explique
les différentes méthodes d'IVG à la
femme celle-ci étant ensuite adressé à
un professionnel pour un entretien
psychosocial une deè consultation après
une période de réflexion où la femme va
signer son consentement à cette
interruption volontaire de grossesse
médicamenteuse et une troisième
consultation qui intervient au cours de
laquelle lui sera délivré le comprimé de
mipégine avec la recommandation de
prendre 48 heur après un autre comprimé
qui provoquera l'évacuation une
prostaglandine qui provoque l'évacuation
de
l'œuf une 4ème visite est nécessaire
auprès du médecin c'est une visite
obligatoire au 15e jour pour contrôler
la vacuité utérine sachant qu'il n'est
pas rare dans cette actuellement dans
ces IVG médicamenteuses d'avoir des
complications hémorragiques dans cette
période et des échecs 3 à 4 % des IVG
dans des IVG médicamenteuses dans tous
les cas le médecin est tenu de s'assurer
d'un bilan sanguin qui est nécessaire
pour détecter une éventuelle
contre-indication à cette méthode et de
demander un groupage changuin comme vous
le voyez mes chers collègu il s'agit là
d'un acte qui est loin d'être anodin et
je ne suis pas sûr que les sches-femmes
dans leur rôle traditionnal de donner la
vie soit très demandeuse il en existe
certes qu'il souhaite mais celles que
j'ai pu contacter on un avis très
réservé aussi sur ce de BIS je souhaite
qu'on puisse obtenir un vote séparé par
ce que un pu
bien monsieur Barbier madame Marie-
thérèe Hermange a demandé aussi la
parole sur l'article 22
bis madame la ministre mes chers
collègues hier madame la ministre vous
nous disiez que vos parents vous avveent
donné cette capacité d'être résistante
et vous nous l'avez montré les miens
m'ont donné cette capacité d'espérer
tant qu'un combat n'a pas été livré
jusqu'au bout car je je mesure les
conséquences de de cet article et de
notre vote
et je voudrais éclairer notre assemblée
d'abord pour rappeler que avant la
séance à l'Assemblée nationale madame
Polti devant la forte opposition des
sages-femmes parce que disait-elle je la
cite la profession des sages-femmes
n'est pas prête à retirer son amendement
comment donc dans l'espace d'un mois et
demi de mois la profession se elle
devenue
prête de plus madame la ministre vous
l'avez vous-même dit à l'Assemblée vous
attendez un rapport actuellement en
préparation rapport qui doit vous être
donné par l'Institut national de la
santé et de la recherche et les
résultats d'une mission
d'évaluation mené par l'Inspection
générale des affaires sociales qui vous
permettront de disposer des nombreuses
données concernant l'IVG pourquoi donc
légiférer dans la précipitation sans
attendre des évaluations sérieuses ma
trè observation tient aux contradiction
de cet article cet article propose la
pratique de l'IVG
médicamenteuse là où le taux de recours
à l'IVG est conséquent mais l'écrire
ainsi c'est dire quelque part que la
prescription du RU
486 délivrée par les sages-femmes à
vocation à être une pilule
contraceptive alors qu'elle est une IVG
en conséquence elle ne diminuera pas le
nombre d'avortements mais
l'augmentera deuxème contradiction
comment va s'articuler cet article avec
l'article R
4127 324 du code de la santé publique
régissant le code de déontologie des
sages-femmes qui stipule je cite aucune
sage-femme n'est tenue de concourir à
une interruption volontaé de grossesse
va-t-on devoir instaurer une clause de
conscience dans le code de déontologie
des
sages-femmes 4e observation
elle comment articuler comme l'a dit
Gilbert Barbier le 22 bis nouveau avec
le dernier alinéa du Grand 2 qui indique
l'exercice de la profession de
sage-femme peut comporter également la
réalisation de consultation
contraception sous réserve que la
sage-femme adresse la femme à un médecin
en cas de situation pathologique et
alors d'un coup d'un seul ce ne serait
plus nécessaire en cas d'IVG
médicamenteuse enfin 5è observation
elle tient au fait que cette
prescription n'a rien d'anodin sur le
plan de la santé de la femme je vous lis
le rapport de Madame Poletti l'IVG
médicament use ne peut pas convenir à
toutes aux femmes les plus fragiles ou
les plus isolées notamment si le
développement de cette méthode a permis
un accès plus facile à l'avortement
favorisant ainsi la réduction des délais
de prise en charge et si le suivi
médical est organisé en liaison avec un
établissement de santé l'accompagnement
apporté à la femme est forcément moindre
qu'au cours d'une
hospitalisation or la prise des
comprimés peut entraîner des douleur
importante ou soulever de fortes
inquiétudes je lis aussi le Vidal comme
l'a dit Gilbert
Barbier risque d'échec de la méthode qui
est de l'ordre de 1 à 7 et5i %. comment
gère-t-on et dcellon une grossesse
extrautérine qui assurra le suivi le
médecin ou la sage-femme le le Vidal
précise je cite la patiente doit être
informé de la surv de métroragie
prolongé parfois abondante jusqu'à 12
jours après la prise du mifégine les mé
les métroragies surviennent dans la
quasi totalité des cas et non ne sont
nullement une preuve d'expulsion
complète au-delà les effets indésirables
sont nombreux au niveau de l'appareil
génital et de l'appareil digestif il est
important que nous soyons informés de
l'ensemble de ces données c'est la
raison pour laquelle me semble-t-il
entériner C article 22 bis nous mène
bien plus loin qu'une simple
expérimentation et nous oblige à tousser
au socle déontologique des sages-femmes
c'est la raison pour laquelle s'il est
dissocié je voterai contre ce V de BIS
sur
l'article madame bon madame la ministre
je crois qu'il y a madame DIN
aussi 2
oui madame Dini aussi demander la parole
intervenant au quel cas je répondrais à
l' il vaudrait peut-être mieux madame
Dinis c'est sur le 22 bis que vous
demandez aussi la parole bon alors
allez-y monsieur le
Président en ce qui me concerne je
voterai contre la
dissociation du du dernier paragraphe du
22 vis et j'ai à cœur d'expliquer et de
replacer dans son contexte cette
disposition elle vise en effet à
permettre au sag-femmes de pratiquer
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
par voie
médicamenteuse le dispositif tel qu'il
est prévu est très encadré puisqu'il
s'agit d'une expérimentation qui sera
menée dans une région connaissant déjà
un fort Tau d'ibg et mise en place après
consultation des professionnels
concernés nous ne sommes plus dans un
débat pour ou contre l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse aujourd'hui
celle-ci est un un droit pour chaque
femme je je je regrette également que
d'entendre dire que cette disposition
encouragera le recours à l'IGB aucune
femme ne choisit d'avorter par plaisir
je citerai sur ce point précis le
docteur Martin vinkel queles que soient
les circonstances l'IVG marque les
femmes même si ces femmes ont choisi
d'avorter cette marque n'est pas
nécessairement indélébile ou irréparable
ni même éternelle et elle existe
contrairement à ce que suggéraent les
discours les plus réactionnaires après
25 ans de légalisation de l'IVG je n'ai
jamais vu de femmes utiliser l'IVG comme
une méthode contraceptive fin de
citation permettre aux sages-femmes de
pratiquer l'IVG par voie médicamenteuse
c'est en assurer un meilleur accès c'est
offrir une meilleure prise en charge des
femmes une prise en charge d'ailleurs à
laquelle participeront également les
centres de planning familial en effet le
décret du 16 mai 2009 les y autorise
désormais l'IVG par voie médicamenteuse
n'est possible hors hôpital qu'auprès
des médecins de ville conventionné avec
un établissement de santé dans certaines
zones ces derniers sont peu nombreux je
tiens à souligner qu'une grande majorité
des sages-femmes sont favorables à cette
délégation de compétences le
casasf qui regroupe les associations et
syndicat de sag-femmes cadres étudiantes
enseignantes libérales et des praciens
de l'obstétrique déclare dans le dernier
numéro de la revue de l'Ordre des
sages-femmes je cite l'IVG
médicamenteuse est de nos jours un droit
incontestable des femmes qui reste
cependant assez difficile d'accès dans
ce cadre les sages-femmes sont les
professionnels les plus indiqués pour
participer à cette action de santé
publique et combler le manque d'élétaire
dans ce domaine fin de citation je
regrette que cette disposition soit
dissociée du reste de l'article celui
porte sur les nouvelles missions
reconnues aux sag-femmes principalement
en matière de suivi gynécologique non
pathologique de consultation en matière
de contraception de prescription des
différents types de contraceptifs nous
le savons les expériences de certains
pays européens l'ont démontré la forte
diminution du nombre d'IVG va de paire
avec une amélioration des pratiques
contraceptives nous devons renforcer
l'information des femmes en matière de
contraception afin que chacune d'entre
elles bénéficie de la méthode
contraceptive qui lui convient le mieux
nous devons aussi garantir l'accès à
l'IVG aux femmes qui au cours de leur
vie n'ont d'autres choix que d'y avoir
recours c'est pourquoi mes chers
collègues je vous demanderai de voter le
maintien de cette disposition j'ajoute
que il me semble tout à fait opportun
que des sages-femmes qui sont
majoritairement des femmes puissent être
l'interlocuteur privilégié des très
jeunes filles pour qui cette disposition
est extrêmement importante vous
remerci alors madame BL madame Blandin
madame l'oratrice précédente s'est très
bien exprimé je ne rentrerai donc pas
dans les détails je dirais simplement
que nous soutenons le maintien de
l'article 22 bis au nom des droits
acquis des femmes et je le dis très
sereinement nous avons confiance dans
les sages-femmes nous nous mettons dans
leurs mains pour donner la vie et cette
révolution intense dans notre organisme
n'est rien à côté des missions nouvelles
que nous voulons lui confier dans
l'article 22 B c'est donc en toute
confiance que nous le soutenons alors
madame
chéinger oui je vais être breve je vais
aussi me joindre donc au propos de
Madame Dini et puis de Madame blonden
tout à fait d'accord il faut qu'on qu'on
a que cet article soit maintenu madame
Dupon
que il y a au début de l'article on dit
que l'exercice de la procession de
sachefarm
elle doit adresser un médecin en cas de
situation pathologique mais si le
médecin lui-même a pas voulu procéder à
l'avortement est-ce qu'il acceptera de
suivre de faire le suivi de la patiente
de la sage-femme et moi j'estime qu'on
donne aux sag-femm une responsabilité
absolument énorme qui risque de les
entraîner dans des pour poursuite
judiciaire importante parce que s'il y a
un problème avec la j'appellerai la
parturiante que l'avortement thérape
médicamenteux se passe mal c'est la
sage-femme qui sera poursuivie et et moi
je pense que le médecin se sera défaussé
envers la la sage-femme et j'estime que
on n pas le droit d'imposer aux
sag-femmes parce que Madame Dini dit la
majorité des sages-femmes est pour cette
délégation et il y a contrario une
énorme beaucoup de S femme qui refuse en
disant notre vocation n'est pas de tuer
des enfants mais de les aider à vivre
alors moi je pense que les médecins
doivent prendre leur responsabilité
avant qu'on donne cette délégation aux
sages-femmes parce que quand les
sages-femmes auront les mêmes problèmes
aujourd'hui vis-à-vis de l'avortement
que les médecins on cherchera une autre
délégation vers d'autres paramédicaux et
moi j'estime ça très grave et on risque
d'entraîner la société très loin bon
madame dum attendez mes chers collègues
monsieur God frroid ne vous énervez
pas c'est Agassa en laisser la liberté
d'expression à tout le
monde pas beaucoup oui je voudrais dire
juste d'une façon non justement
passionnée que il ne faudrait pas que
les débats que nous avons et les
échanges sur un sujet aussi grave puisse
en fait remettre en cause ce droit
fondamental qui est l'avortement et qui
est une vraie liberté pour les femmes en
France donc je crois que prenons garde à
notre vote
aujourd'huiésident
ficher je crois que c'est un débat bon
qui nous renvoie toujours à une j'allais
dire une fracture qui pour un certain
nombre de nos collègues suscite de toute
évidence bon on pourrait aller à la
polémique et cetera mais je crois qu'il
faut respecter le combat des femmes pour
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
mugaddini a très bien résumé les choses
et bien entendu nous sommes pour cet
article 22 bis donc nous le voterons et
je n'allonge pas plus le débat mais nous
pourrions réaffirmer nos positions de
principe et surtout dans un groupe qui
est composé majoritairement de femmes et
bien nous soutenons cet article là bon
alors mes chers collègues avant de
donner la parole
au rapporteur ensuite au président de la
commission si demande et à Madame le
Ministre que je suis saisi quand même
d'une demande de séparation de Monsieur
Barbier par conséquent j'applique le
règlement donc donnez votre sentiment
monsieur le rapporteur oui monsieur le
Président je vais être bref vous
inquiétez pas je voudrais juste dire
d'abord que la demande de séparation a
été faite par Monsieur Barbi dans le
cadre de la Commission et que la
Commission l'a
accepté ensuite je voudrais réintervenir
venir en me joignant complètement au
propos de Madame Dumas et en disant bien
que nous ne devons pas ici faire le
procès de l'interduption volontaire de
grossesse sinon on refait un autre débat
qui a eu lieu à 40 ans mais à 30 ans en
arrière enfin je voudrais ajouter et là
c'est pas à titre de rapporteur
puisque le la Commission n'a pas donné
d'avis sur sur le reste mais à titre
personnel et en tant que médecin je
joins je me joins complètement à ce qu'a
dit Madame Dini que j'approuve
complètement bon
madame non non madame la ministre
maintenant alors il faut d'abord
rappeler qu'il y a des avancées majeures
dans leur tile 22 bis puisque les
sages-femmes pourront accomplir un
certain nombre d'actions de prévention
elles pourront proposer un dépistage du
cancer du colle de l'utérus au cours du
premier examen prénatal et je crois que
ça facilitera l'accès de femmes jeunes
euh à à cet acte de pr
elles pourront également un suivi
gynécologique de prévention et prescrire
toute méthode contraceptive je pense que
dans le référentiel de formation il
faudra sans doute améliorer ce
référentiel de formation en particulier
pour la pose de dispositif intrautérrain
mais bien sûr tout cela relève de la
voie réglementaire le contenu de la
formation n'est pas de nature
législative alors vous avez à travers
une disposition de la commission des
affaires sociales du Sénat euh ouvert
également la perspective d'un
élargissement progressif des compétences
des sages-femmes en matière de santé des
femmes en autorisant ces professionnels
à pratiquer des interruptions
volontaires de grossesse par voie
médicamenteuse à titre expérimental dans
une région connaissant un taux important
de recours à l'IVG alors finalement il y
a il y a trois questions qui sont posées
euh vous avez très justement les uns et
les autres indiquer qu'il ne s'agissait
pas de remettre sur le chantier le débat
sur l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse c'est un acquis c'est une
liberté des femmes ce n'est pas le lieu
du débat deuxième question qui est posée
est-ce que les sages-femmes ont la
compétence pour exercer ces
actes véritablement elles l'ont
évidemment je il y a un programme actuel
de formation des sages-femmes qui
contient d'ors et déjà plus de 120 heur
de cours ainsi que des stages en
gynécologie sur ces ces sujets donc
véritablement
elle dispose des compétences nécessaires
je m'en suis assuré pour l'exercice
d'une technique qui ne comporte aucun
geste invasif troisème question qui est
posée c'est celle de de la conscience
même si ce n'est pas évidemment ma ma
vision certains professionnels médecins
ou sag-femme peuvent pour des raisons
que je n'ai pas à évaluer ici la volonté
ne pas recourir à ces actes ne pas
effectuer ces actes bien évidemment et
je l'affirme devant vous en aucun cas un
professionnel médecin ou sache femme ne
peut se trouver dans la situation
d'effectuer contre sa conscience
euh un acte tel qu'une IVG
médicamenteuse et elles pourront les
sages-femmes il et elle puisquil y a
quelques hommes pourront faire valoir
bien évidemment comme les médecins la
clause de conscience et garderont toute
liberté personnelle quant à la
réalisation d'IVG par voie
médicamenteuse donc sur ces trois sujets
je pense avoir été totalement clair
quelle est pour la
séparation alors sur
le bon alors euh il faut d'abord que
nous prenions le 140 rectifié bis de
Madame ferra et après nous verrons si
nous faisons la séparation ou
pas merci monsieur le président madame
la ministre mes chers collègues l'objet
du présent amendement est d'encadrer le
dispositif qui vient d'être adopté par
not notre assemblée concernant la
prescription de contraceptif par les
sages-femmes B que nous pourrions
adopt prenant acte du fait que les
sages-femmes pourront désormais
prescrire à l'instar des médecins
gynécologues des contraceptifs locaux et
hormonaux il est indispensable de
renforcer leur formation à la
contraception en effet les sages-femmes
ne reçoivent à l'heure actuelle et
d'après mes informations qu'une
formation de 20h à la gynécologie et à
la contraception de leur cursus
ce volume horaire est à l'évidence
insuffisant les sages-femmes seraient
donc si la loi était adoptée en l'état
amener à établir des actes médicaux dont
les conséquences sur la santé des
patientes peuvent être très graves sans
avoir reçu de formation gynécologique
intensive préalable le contraceptif est
un médicament qui comporte des contre
des contre-indications et sa
prescription est un acte médical à part
entière par ailleurs il est prévu que la
sagefemme adresse le patient au médecin
en cas de situation pathologique comment
évaluer quelle situation peut se révéler
pathologique si la formation en matière
de contraception est
insuffisante une augmentation
substantielle des heures de formation à
la contraception et à la gynécologie
pour les sages-femmes à l'heure où leur
cursus est reconnu par ce projet de loi
comme ayant le niveau master est
indispensable pour leur assurer une
appréciation suffisante des situations
auxquelles elles seront confrontées
al sur l'amendement 140 rectifi bis
justement de Madame ferra quel est
l'avis de la commission oui parler du
contenu du programme de formation c'est
plus réglementaire que législatif c'est
le premier point le deuxième point
madame la ministre en intervenant il y a
10 minutes ou 5 minutes a bien parlé de
la formation des sages-femmes à la
contraception à la gynécologie il me
semble donc que votre amendement est en
partie satisfait mais j'attends l'avis
de madame la ministre sur le sujet alors
l'avis du Gouvernement madame la
ministre sur l'amendement de Madame
ferrra
oui euh une réponse de fond et de forme
de forme sur le plan juridique car le
contenu des formations on l'a répété à
de nombreuses reprises est totalement de
nature réglementaire
euh je au niveau de l'IVG médicamenteuse
il y a vraiment la formation nécessaire
sur l'IVG médicamenteuse j'ai indiqué
que très certainement sur le la les
questions de de contraception il faudra
sur la pose des dispositifs intrautérin
sans doute une formation complémentaire
mais bien entendu je mène cette cette
discussion avec les les organisations
représentatives de sag-femme et bien
entendu de médecin pour adapter les
référentiels mais il y a pas de il y a
pas de sujet il y a pas de souci hein
donc donc une demande de retraite cet
amendement
euh très bien Madame ferat merci
beaucoup alors mes chers collègues dans
ce cas-là avec avis de la commission
avec sagesse du gouvernement on peut
procéder à un vote séparé et par
priorité sur le deux bis nouveau à
l'intérieur de l'article 22 bis et par
scrutin public puisque le groupe RDS le
demande monsieur Barbier
oui monsieur le président id chers
collègues madame le ministre je crois
que il faut lever toute ambiguité sur la
démarche que
j'effectue parce que contrairement à ce
qui a été dit annoncé je crois qu'il
s'agit d'être loin d'un acte anodin et
qui pose des problèmes des problèmes de
responsabilité les sages-femmes auront
certainement des contrats d'assurance à
revoir parce que il y a un certain
nombre d'échecs
et simplement j'ai entendu des ftion et
notamment des donneurs de leçons dans
cette
affaire je vais poser une question pour
élever le doigt quels sont ceux qui en
75 ont pratiqué des interruptions
volontaires de
grossesse je lève je lève la main et je
peux vous dire que pour suivre madame
veille dans sa démarche en 75 c'était
pas très facile et que aujourd'hui il
s'agit pas pour moi de remettre en cause
la possibilité pour les femmes de
pratiquer une intertion volontaire de
grossesse je dis que sur le plan
technique sur le plan médical il s'agit
d'un acte difficile psychologiquement et
physiquement et que notamment pour avoir
vu des hémorragies à la suite de C de
cette pratique et bien je dis qu'il faut
qu'il y ait un contrôle de médecin je ne
mets pas en cause la compétence que
peuvent avoir les sages-femmes mais je
dis qu'il s'agit d'un acte suffisamment
grave pour laisser dans l'état actuel
des choses
cette cette affaire entre les mains des
médecins c'est tout monsieur Vassel a
demandé la
parole monsieur GODF aussi monsieur
monsieur le Président Mad ministre mes
chers
collègues tout au long de l'examen de ce
texte de loi nous avons été
particulement attentifs à aux
précautions et à la qualité à la bonne
pratique des soins au profil de nos
concitoyens il ne s'est pas passé de de
titre ou de chapitres de la loi sans que
le gouvernement et nous-même insistions
sur cet aspect des choses
deuxièmement je pense qu'il faut pas se
tromper de débat ça a été dit par deux
de nos collègues précédemment évitons de
faire l'amalgame entre l'IVG et le
dispositif du texte actuel je crois que
ceux qui cherchent à faire de la malgap
c'est pour trouver les esprits et pour
mieux plaider en faveur de leur de leur
choix et de leur vote trème
considération sur la compétence
professionnelle
le sénateur Barbier a beaucoup insisté
sur cet aspect des choses même si le
niveau de compétence des sag-femme peut
ne pas être mise en cause dans la mesure
où comme l'a dit Madame Bachelot cela
nécessitera quand même une formation
complémentaire donc de ce point de vue
l'amendement de notre collègue du groupe
centriste n'était pas inutile même s'il
y avait lieu donc d'en préciser les
choses mais j'ai bien compris que le
gouvernement avait l'intention par voir
règlementaire donc de veiller à ce que
cette formation complémentaire soit
suffisante 4èe considération avant d'
terminer par un dernier point vous savez
que nous avons adopté dans la
Constitution ce qu'on appelle le
principe de précaution est-ce que le
principe de précaution ne doit
s'appliquer que pour des dispositions
qui échappent à toutes les questions
sanitaires et de santé à partir du
moment où cet acte est un acte grave que
nous avions parfaitement encadré
par des dispositions législatives
antérieures moi je m'interroge sur la
perdidance d'une telle initiative qui
tente à banaliser un acte qui n'a pas
vocation à l'être alors il y a des
problèmes de conscience chacun en
fonction de ses convictions bien entendu
peut ne pas partager ce dispositif mais
en qualité de législateur et de
parlementaire donc est-ce que en
adoptant cette disposition nous
considérons que nous n'avons pas bien
rempli notre mission lorsque nous avons
légiférer sur ce texte et sur cette
accès à l'interruption volontaire de
grandesse pour nos
concitoyens je crains fort que nos
concitoyens pour une partie d'entre eux
analyse la disposition que nous allons
adopter comme une banalisation et rien
que le fait de passer par la voie de
l'expérimentation démontre si besoin
était que nous ne sommes pas si sûrs de
nous dans l'action que nous proposons
parce que si le fait de passer par les
sagesfemmes ne posait pas de problème
pourquoi passer par la voie
d'expérimentation si nous avions toutes
les sécurités les garanties pour que les
sagesfemmes le le le fais en toute
assurance le fasse en toute assurance
donc personnellement je suis très
réservé sur cette disposition c'est la
raison pour laquelle je ne l'adopterai
pas parce que je ne souhaite pas que les
femmes soient confrontées à des
complications médicales et je pense que
la meilleure sécurité pour elle c'est
que cette interruption volontaire de
grossesse soit faite peut-être avec le
concours d'une sa fan mais sous
l'autorité d'un médecin en présence d'un
médecin ou dans un établissement de
santé qui lui apporte toutes les
garanties je pense que c'est de leur
intérêt et c'est de l' intérêt à nous
tous qui sommes en charge de la S de la
protection de nos habitants en terme de
santé publique alors Monsieur gdeefroid
oui monsieur le Président Madame la
ministre mes chers collègues très
rapidement tout d'abord je voudrais je
voudrais dire à mon collègue monsieur
Barbier que effectivement les sénateurs
ou sénatrices qui ne sont pas médecins
ne peuvent pas témoigner comme lui mais
ce n'est pas pour autant que nous nous
intéressons du problème et que le cas
échéant nous n'ayons pas conscience de
toutes les difficultés et des des
perturbations graves que cela peut
entraîner tant sur le plan de la santé
que sur le plan psychologique nous en
sommes tous bien conscients tout à
l'heure si j'ai un petit peu réagi c'est
je rebondis sur le propos de notre
collègue monsieur Vassel il est quand
même notoire que dans cet hémicycle dès
que l'on parle de ce sujet on retrouve
toujours les mêmes avec les mêmes
arguments et que malgré tout on ne peut
pas déconnecter les deux chose je le dis
comme je le pense on peut ne pas
partager mon sentiment mais on le vit
régulièrement et c'est à chaque fois sur
des textes de santé récemment nous avons
eu déjà ce débat ici et nous avions été
amenés nous à soutenir madame la
ministre dans le combat qu'elle menait
trème question que je vous souhaiterai
posé vous avez dit monsieur le Président
tout à l'heure le groupe RDSE en parlant
de notre collègue monsieur Barbier
j'aimerais savoir si c'est l'ensemble du
groupe RDSE qui défend cette position ou
si c'est une position de Monsieur
Barbier parce que sur le vote qui va
intervenir ça a quand même une certaine
importance bien monsieur Leem
oui monsieur le Président moi je crois
que dans ce dans ce débat madame la
ministre dans dans sa synthèse a été
très claire elle a posé elle a fait
trois observation on fait et dans ces
trois observations moi je fais confiance
dans ce cadre là à à ce qui a été relevé
première observation on ne refait pas le
débat sur
l'IVG je crois que là il y a un accord
semble-t-il unanime du moins j'ose
l'espérer on ne refait pas le débat sur
l'IVG deuxième point qu'elle l'a
souligné fortement est-ce que la
sche-femme à la compéten technique sa
réponse est oui elle a même apporté un
certain nombre de précisions techniqu
sur nombre d'heures par ailleurs en
complément il y aura des formations qui
vont être mis en sus pour encore
conforter et en plus expérimentation je
veux dire que dans ce cadrelà le risque
est minimum trème point soulevé par
Madame le Ministre observver c'est que
il y a la clause de conscience voilà
hein il y a une liberté pour la
schefemme de ne pas faire si elle estime
pour tout un ensemble de raisons la
possibilité qu'il y ait pour des raisons
peut-être qu'on ignore personnelles mais
aussi que sa technicité mais c'est à
elle de le dire à elle d'en prendre la
responsabilité c'est le cas pour
l'ensemble des médecins moi j'ai été
pendant 35 ans directeur général de
centre hospitalier j'ai eu des médecins
qui ont voulu ne pas appliquer
l'interruption de grossesse ils ont en
conscience pris ses décisions rien leur
a été reproché c'était leur liberté ça
sera la même chose pour les sagesfemmes
dans ce cadre-là moi j'invite mes
collègues à soutenir la position pris
par notre
commission vous venez de suivre l'examen
du projet de loi Hôpital patients santé
et territoire pour revoir cette séance
notre site internet publsenat.fr merci
de votre attention et à très bientôt sur
Public
Sénat